we all through it three thousand dollars
328 thank you
next we go in depth with david
halberstam
[Music]
david halberstam has been writing for
nearly 50 years first as a newspaper
reporter covering civil rights and
foreign affairs his coverage of vietnam
won him the pulitzer at age 30. he's
produced 17 books including the
best-selling trilogy on power the best
and the brightest the powers that be and
the reckoning for the next three hours
you'll meet david hauberstam in depth
we'll take your calls and talk about his
writing career including his latest book
war in a time of peace
david halberstam as a writer i'm
wondering about your instincts since
september 11th especially since so many
of the books that you have done have
been what people call first drafts of
history
well i
you know you
want to go with
the events i mean
by chance the book that was out war in a
time of peace was really a book that was
a prelude to the events in effect why
was america napping in that period since
the end of the cold war so it seemed and
i think is very germane i mean why were
we caught so much by surprise why was
our um our agenda political and media so
trivial and that's what i try and
explore the subtitle really could be why
america napped not unlike the
john kennedy book
why england swept but now i have to
start thinking of what do i do next and
what are you doing i mean as i observe
doing a lot of reporting and i've done
some writing i did a piece for vanity
fair uh in a special issue on
on what it meant i mean how the world
had changed on that one morning i mean
from a time of peace to a time of war
i did that i've done the introduction
for a
a collection of great magnum photos of
the day and i'm doing a piece on a
firehouse for vanity fair a firehouse
two blocks from us which lost 11 men all
the men who went down other than one
really uh were lost there i mean
heartbreaking so i'm doing that and then
i'm trying to figure out whether to
change the direction of my next book to
something that connects to this and i
think i will
i want to introduce you to this program
david howardson will be with us for
three hours in total we will be talking
here in our studio in washington for
about the next 20 minutes and then we
invite your telephone calls and those
calls can come in on the topic of any of
the many books he's written or other
pieces by him that you've read
and we'll tell you how to get through to
the program if you uh live in the
eastern and central time zones we've got
a number that you can use and those
watching in the western half of the
united states will have a separate line
and again now you can begin dialing at
any time during the next few minutes but
we'll go to calls about 20 minutes from
now i want to turn to that vanity fair
piece that you referenced the special
edition that they put out on september
11th to read for two reasons so that
people who aren't familiar with your
work can get a sense of your writing but
also your observations you write we have
witnessed a turning point in american
history the beginning of what i think is
going to be one of the most challenging
of our geopolitical struggles because
the enemy is so difficult to do battle
with because he offers so poor target
for our high technology weaponry and
because no small part of his strength is
his patience which he matches against
our innate impatience an inevitable
byproduct of a dynamic society
constantly in some sort of overdrive
since you've done so many studies of
modern america
how prepared are we and what do you
think the ultimate success of
us doing battle with this sort of enemy
might be i think in the long run we'll
do well i think we are ill-prepared
democracies really always are i think
they are slower to react i think
everybody now is
you know looking and
finding fault with everyone else why
weren't the intelligence systems better
why weren't the security systems better
why don't our bombing runs against the
taliban work better are our special
forces or delta forces going in i mean i
think we forget that we were
ill-prepared at the time of pearl harbor
ill prepared at the time of sputnik uh
we the the early experiences of american
comrade troops in north africa were not
in fact particularly good i mean i
there is a learning curve and a growing
and and i think democracies and
particularly this one because we've
always been protected by our two oceans
we're slower than most but i have great
faith in in the democracy particularly
once it focuses and gives high priority
on its agenda to it i
i agree i have great faith in this
country and and i think that um
totalitarians always underestimate us i
mean
hitler and
imperial japanese thought we were soft
and decadent the
the leaders of the soviet union thought
we were soft and decadent mr khrushchev
said
he would bury us his his son teaches at
my daughter's college in providence
rhode island now uh
mr um milosevic told our diplomats that
we were too soft and could not take
death and and bin laden has said the
same way but i think our priorities are
different we just do it a little more
slowly
once we put the full resource of this
country at war
this is not a country you want to tinker
with or toy with this is a very powerful
very resilient country before we dig
into some of the specifics of your books
why don't you tell me how it all got
started
you mean when i left college and all the
the only thing i was really ever good at
was it was journalism i
went from public high schools and we
grew up in first the new yorker area in
new york area then we followed my father
who when he went back in the service to
army bases in texas and even the mayo
clinic i've got a little cut here my
father was a doctor and before he went
overseas we're in the mayo clinic and
when i played hockey at the age of about
nine or ten and went on my chin about
the second time i got sewn up at the
mayo clinic there's a little stitch a
pretty little scar there and then
winston connecticut and we went to and
then public schools then harvard and i
had a learning disability i was it turns
out i was very bad student i i probably
my grades averaged out to a c or below
but i was good at one thing
the undergraduate daily newspaper i was
managing editor of the harvard crimson
and by instinct it came easily and
naturally whereas uh the kind of
learning disability med learning in
abstract learning large textbooks large
lecture halls were hard my i can still
see my attention span floating out the
window of those lecture halls
i graduated in 1955 i wanted to be a
journalist it was i thought it was the
one thing i really could do it was a
year after brown versus board of
education there was
i thought the south would be interesting
mississippi the most interesting because
it would be the monster council i was
hired to work on a new paper in jackson
in jackson mississippi i got down there
the man who hired me it turned out
didn't even work for the newspaper but i
ended up on the smallest daily in
mississippi in west point mississippi in
the northeast hill country i did that
for about a year then went for four very
happy years on the nashville tennessee
in which i think was the best paper in
the south in the civil rights movement
where i was taught and worked with
wonderful colleagues a great graduate
school for me
then went to the new york times where i
was hit hired by the great
editor journalist of an era scotty
reston when there joined the paper paper
the day after john kennedy's election 40
41 years ago
went very didn't do terribly well in
washington didn't have a real job i
didn't get traction but they said well
he's young and sing on the
covers as civil rights will send him to
africa the congo was blowing up i became
six months from covering
police beat in
in nashville i was covering the biggest
story overseas in in the breakdown of
the
order in the congo and almost won the
pulitzer prize there
one year i i think i was running up to
walter littman and then a year a year
that and i went to vietnam as the first
new york times full-time correspondent
in i think it was
summer of 1962 39 years ago
that's interesting there's one little
thing there and that is
when i was at 27 28 in order to sample
the tensions and confrontations of our
time
i had to go 12 000 miles away
to saigon and now late in my life almost
40 years later they have struck they
have come home to within five miles of
where i live in new york city so and
could you have ever expected that
happening not then i mean gradually more
recently there's been pretty evidence
that there were no immunities and that
terror would hit terrorism would hit a
new york i mean a major american city
and the most likely one would be new
york why did you make the transition to
books
well like i always liked the idea of
writing books and my heroes had always
been people like theodore white and john
gunther i thought there was sort of a
permanence a little bit i don't i don't
think any writers ever
immortal but there's a little
less
there's a little more immortality to
book writing a little more permanence a
little more
sense that what you have done lasts a
little bit longer and doesn't go out
wrapping fish and so i saw that and i
thought that would be i mean teddy white
had done those wonderful early books
fire in the ashes and then the making of
the president when i was younger and and
i think one of the things that also
really affected me was being in vietnam
i mean i had a very good run there the
paper that i
worked for
the times was really very good to me but
you came away with some of the
frustrations of being a daily journalist
uh from there
you were nice enough to send i think
your very earliest first book came out
40 years ago it's a novel reference i
wrote two novels that's the first one
and it's okay i mean i wrote it as a
it's based on a a true event in this
little town in mississippi and uh it it
it it's okay what i was the process of
doing was finding out that i wasn't a
novelist i have to show the photograph
on the back it is 60s retro
i think i'm 25 years old when that
picture's taken
but you moved from novels and and moved
to what style how would you describe
what it is you try to do with yourself i
write non-fiction
journalism rapportage that has gradually
morphed into being
history i'm now i i'm really a
contemporary historian as much as
anything else now one of the really nice
things that's happened to me late in my
career i was elected to rather elite
group to something called the society of
american historians it's elective it's
elite and i'm there with people like
arthur schlesinger was a great historian
and a really wonderful man who used to
give me those c pluses so it's a very
nice
late looming
victory for me now people are so
familiar with the best and the brightest
but you wrote an earlier book in the
midst of vietnam
called the making of quagmire i i may
have been the person i mean i know
they're talking you know the question of
whether afghanistan and dealing with the
taliban is going to be a quagmire but i
believe i'm the person who put the
phrase quagmire into usage i mean it was
an early that book was written in 1964
and came out in early 1965 and it really
was a pretty pessimistic account of what
was happening i had a little fun with
this i have to tell you we picked up
this copy from a local public library
and one of your readers was writing was
arguing with you i'm sure he was in the
in the margins
for a lot of people you know being a
dissenter on vietnam or a pessimist was
not a
was not a popular thing there there's uh
it's come a long way now i mean 40 years
later 37 years later it's okay to be
more critical of vietnam that book was
banned from the usia library in saigon
when it first came out it was the
american authorities said that it was in
effect a seditious book
and what was your reaction to that at
the time i was not surprised i was
taking so much heat and abuse from the
government john kennedy who had been
president had asked the publisher of the
new york times to pull me from there and
transfer me to
paris or london and lyndon johnson took
time off when he was president from his
you know rather considerable duties as
president to be minister of truth and he
called a neil she and my young colleague
and called neil and me uh traitors to
our country and he told bob sherwood
a writer that we were traitors to our
country so by then i was used to getting
sort of beaten up a little bit
the best and the brightest i was
surprised in one of these anniversary
editions to learn that in some ways the
godmother of the best and the brightest
is a woman that people in politics think
of as a neoconservative dector well i
don't know that i'd call her a midge
doctor i wouldn't call her the god
mother of the book because uh i don't
think she is but she has suggested the
article that became the germ that became
the book i had come back from vietnam in
67 very pessimistic 1968 if you'll
recall was that really
you know classic year in america where
everything where all hell broke loosely
uh the challenge to the war uh the ted
offensive the assassination of martin
king robert kennedy the democratic
convention in chicago which went into
the streets i covered all that for
harper's magazine when it was over i
really was at loose ends in november
and midge dector had suggested she was a
colleague at harper's mcgeorge bundy and
i thought well that's a good idea you
know this allegedly brilliant dean of
harvard when i was there and if he was
so brilliant you know why were he and
the others the architects of this
tragedy so i began a piece for um
harper's magazine that became this long
long piece i think 15 20 000 words about
him but about the others and i think
there's a phrase in that they swept into
office the best and brightest of a
generation and out of that came
eventually and i when i was finished i
called my editor once finished the
magazine piece i called my editor
jim silverman had a at random house and
said this is a book and i that became my
job for the next three or four years
it is also a classic study in the way
that you work would you talk a little
bit about your research style well
i'm really there are people out there
that are documents
reporters i mean for instance iaf stone
worked on documents he had terrible
hearing and he didn't like going to
press conferences because he couldn't
hear so there's great documents man and
other people work brilliantly off
libraries me i'm a journalist so i'm a
reporter so i go and interview people
when i started that book i
you know how and why we went to war in
vietnam i thought you know can i do it
you know who'd be first question is who
might do it better
and i thought well if my friend bernard
fall had not been killed in vietnam
clearly because he was both journalist
and historian he might have done it
better he was a wonderful man he had
more root
rooted on that subject i was a newcomer
pure journalist in those days and then i
thought wait a minute my work at harpers
had gotten better i'd gone from daily
journalism to three or four years at
harper's writing magazine piece so the
intellectual level and i thought the
literary level was beginning to go up
and i thought well if i do this for
three or four years four years and if i
do two and a half years of legwork just
interviewing and i do two interviews a
day
i will have enough great material
that i can get a wonderful book and i
thought well i write as well as most
contemporary historians
and it's a great subject and i have
access to people because i'm enmeshed in
it and um
and i can do this i mean you know why
not me i mean i can intellectually do it
and i can literally do it and i'm going
to give it four years there's nothing
else i want to do or need to do it's an
act of witness it was an active witness
and a passion so i had this odd
confidence of a young man i was 35 when
i began it that it was the only thing
that mattered in my life i didn't have a
lot of money the advance for it was 45
000 which if you take off the agent's
commission is 41 000 and you amortize
that over three or four years uh what
were called copy boys now there i think
news clerks at the new york times would
make more than that but that's what i
wanted to do for those four years
you uh knew when that it was uh going to
be a bestseller
well we didn't know there's a
wonderful story of my friends richard
and
shirley clurman who were wonderful
journalists and they were at lunch or
dinner one day with mike wallace who was
at cbs and you know i said you disappear
when you do a book like this and mike
had that mike was a friend of theirs and
said what oh you know what's
david halperstein doing and
declaring said he's doing a book on how
and why we went to war in vietnam and
and mike who likes to get a lot of put
his name on often i think on other
people's work the way they do it cbs you
know in 60 minutes mike said poor david
i don't think it was ever thought of as
a bet you know bestseller i thought it
was an active witness the idea that it
just exploded on the best seller list
you know was on the new york times list
10 book list 36 weeks it went to number
one it sold i think 200 000 copies
serious book on how and why we went to
war in vietnam no one thought that was
going to happen i mean if you get in
advance for 40 000 what they're really
thinking is you're going to sell about
20 000 copies i think that's what they
bet and it just took off have any
estimate since it's been published so
many times since then it's 30th
anniversary edition i have no earthly
idea i mean i think we've sold
a couple million copies and different
editions i'm i'm very touched by this
new edition because john mccain has
written first off it's the you know it's
the modern library which means i've sort
of gone in the hall of fame that you
know it's you know only kind of people
like bill styron i mean the the big guys
go in there and so i made the i made the
cut but john mccain wrote the
introduction and and that's very moving
to me because as we were talking a
moment earlier uh to have
uh to have been attacked so viciously
by the pentagon and by the white house
and by all sorts of people in the
conservative press
when you're young for being unpatriotic
even as you think you're doing something
rather patriotic which is writing
honestly about a a losing proposition to
have it swing full circle and have
someone i esteem
like john mccain i think a legitimate
american hero and an extraordinary man
to write to have him write the
introduction is really wonderful it's it
really i wrote him a note when he said
he would do it and then cut the end and
i got the injection you i said you in
fact you've made me whole
five minutes until your telephone calls
and questions for david halberstam we uh
encourage you to begin dialing now so
you have a chance to talk with him and
ask about the kinds of things
that you've been seeing in this reading
over the years
what do you think it is about this book
the best and the brightest that has had
so much resonance
well i think first of all it was the
first kennedy revisionist book
that is up till then all the books on
kennedy had been written by in fact what
were people in his employ and they were
very articulate and verbal and there was
a sort of roma because of the terrible
way he was murdered there was a
romanticism i mean this was the greatest
administration ever and each guy was
brighter than the other and it was a
camelot theory and john kennedy was you
know very talented young american
politician but
he was a working politician and they
were there were some warts there and
flaws and so i was the first person who
came through and pushed aside all the
mythology on him i think that secondly i
think it is a really good portrait of
how politics works of who the people
were who got power not elect just
elective power but pri invisible power
the people in the in the core part of
the machinery of national uh politics i
think it's the portraits i think of for
instance of mcnamara the technological
whiz kids who really is a very i think a
limited human being i mean the portrait
of bundy the portrait of the civilian
military i think that stuff's very
strong it stands up
year year after year more and more
documents have been released and they
all validate the end the reporting i
really you know i got all the stuff very
very accurately and it's really a very
good book about a country crossing the
rubicon doesn't
terribly ill-prepared making all the
wrong decisions in all the wrong way and
i am there just pure raw energy i've
caught it i think it's a book that oddly
enough has as much and more validity now
than ever
john mccain senator mccain's
conclusion and what she writes in the
forward is
i very much doubt that americans will
ever again believe that our country has
a native governing class
no
well that's one of the things that that
book talked about because there was a
kind of elite and there were many good
things about the elite but in that
particular
moment it served us very badly and there
was an arrogance a lack of listening to
people they should have listened to
and and and we got we got a lot of stuff
wrong
is is he right do we no longer you said
it we don't have it we don't have an
american establishment anymore it's it's
gone i mean i think the country's so big
it's so meritocratic it's so diverse
there is
there's no elite you could i mean it's
not like
i mean in the old days they all came
from this extraordinary school groton
and you went to grad and then you went
and became secretary of state i mean
it's changed so much that
the only connection groton has is that
the ex-wife of groton graduate madeleine
albright was
secretary of state
if you'll indulge me
this is a bit of
a text that displays that uh kennedy
revisionism you talked about but i'd
like to have you read a little bit of it
sure if i can do that i
picked it up right here uh this
paragraph on the bay of pigs
that's here
this is
this is where it begins where it says if
the bay pigs
if anything
if anything
the bay of pigs had made the kennedy
administration acutely aware
of its vulnerability and determined to
show that it was worthy that this was
not a weak young president unable to
cope with the soviets but that he was
just as tough as they were just as fast
on the draw in the administration those
who were the tough-minded realists were
strengthened those less inclined to use
force were weakened kennedy would soon
have a chance to show whether he was
worthy of his mandate as the upcoming
conference with nikita khrushchev in
vienna in early june a meeting scheduled
so soon after the bay of pigs that the
very holding of it was dubious but he
went through with it and the outcome
rather than lowering tensions increased
them the president left khrushchev in
vienna feeling they'd been bullied more
determined than ever to show khrushchev
that despite his youth despite the bay
of pigs he was someone to conjure with
he would call up the reserves
and flex american muscle in many ways
and of course one of the places was in
vietnam
and there
what you illustrate is something that
you talk about in many of your books
that the idea that foreign policy
doesn't involve domestic politics
is well that's one of the great
illusions you know and that was one of
the things i was really attacking in
those days uh there was this illusion
politics stops at the water's edge and
that wasn't true i mean our foreign
policy was pro profoundly affected by
domestic politics by the mccarthy era by
the fact that um
in the democrats i mean john lyndon
johnson when he made his decisions on
vietnam was absolutely obsessed by the
mccarthy period he would go around
saying that when you know truman and
atchison lost china they lost the
congress and therefore he and therefore
he was not going to be the president of
the united states who lost vietnam
because he would lose the great society
he was terribly fearful of being accused
of being weak on communism because he
had seen what the mccarthy period had
done to truman and atchison take our
first viewer question for you it's from
pagoda new jersey you're on for david
halberstam
hi
uh good afternoon mr havelstein
i was wondering why as a nation right
now that we cannot
rid more of the arabic legal aliens that
are in this country at the moment is it
i have a couple questions but this is
first is it due to
is it politically incorrect do they
help too much with our economic
workforce uh do they bring
um
you know do they help the economy
because we keep having these threats and
we're going to be more vigilant and have
more security yet the people that are
within the borders
for the most part unfortunately are
you know that are causing these
terrorist threats or arabic why can't we
get rid of them well there are a lot of
loyal
citizens of
muslim origin and
arab backgrounds and we once before in
our nation's history in december 41 and
early 42 rounded up all kinds of people
japanese nisei
japanese
who were american citizens and put them
in in effect uh camps or whether you
want to call them concentration camps i
don't think they were but they were
detention centers and i think it's a
blot on our history and i think we're
trying in a free society where we are
trust the loyalty of our fellow citizens
to be better this time and we want to be
able and i think it's a real test of a
free society to separate those citizens
our backgrounds who are loyal and love
this country from those who may be a
threat it's difficult it's going to take
time
i think we can do this i think we've
been very slow and we've obviously got
to have more people in the security and
intelligence services with arabic
backgrounds i mean who speak the
languages work over there here i mean
and work here but i mean just rounding
up people as you seem to suggest i think
that that would be a great victory for
our opponents our adversaries they would
make us fear each other and we don't
want that to this point in your writing
career at least in book form you have
not dug into the american politics of
the middle east
no i haven't and that's probably because
i'm jewish when i joined the new york
times uh
they didn't send reporters who were
jewish to the to the middle east there
was a sort there was that's changed i
think tom friedman's a good example of
that but in those days there was sort of
uh it was off limits i think they felt
you were going to be under too much
pressure and as such i didn't have it
early on in my curriculum vitae probably
in addition there's always the feeling
that you know if you're jewish and you
write about the middle east you're going
to get attacked so much
from either side you know you're either
going to be called someone who's
toadying to the israelis or as often
happens a self-hating jew if you're in
some way critical so i thought well
there are enough really good people
qualified people who do that and
i think tom friedman is really so so
gifted and there are a lot of other
people that i was free to do other
things so i i've never been drawn to it
in part i think because i didn't work
there when i was young hammond indiana
yes you're on the air
is this
about symbo
do you have a question for david
haberstein
well i was watching c-span here okay
thank you call we're going to move on to
chicago and you're on for david
halberstam
i'd like to ask whether he whether mr
halberstam sees any parallels between
the decision-making processes
that led to vietnam and the
decision-making processes that are going
on now with respect to
containing terrorism
well i think they're very different i
mean i think you're talking apples and
oranges i think vietnam was a historic
miscalculation the wrong war the wrong
time the wrong place where we misread
history i mean one of the things i
really remember is the patch that all
american
troops wore when they went there and it
was a sword
piercing
the wall of china and that was in which
we were there to pierce the wall of
china as if we were fighting communist
china but of course
vietnamese nationalism which is what we
run ran into there and why we didn't win
the war i mean the uh ho chi minh and
fem van dang and vogue and japan leaders
at the side had much greater title to
nationalism because they'd kicked the
french out then our vietnamese the arvin
and the government in the south but
vietnamese nationalism is historically
opposed to china so we really completely
misread that and we went rather
gratuitously into
an unwinnable war this is something very
different because this is a war that has
come to find us these people have in
effect declared war on us and now we are
trying to figure out and it's hard to do
it under pressure and we everybody
expects the processes to work very well
we're trying to figure i i i
think that this is a pretty competent
administration struggling under you know
difficult circumstances going from a
time of peace into a time of war to do
the right thing i don't see many
parallels yet i don't see any hubris
here
las vegas you're on for david howard
stan
hi susan and hi mr halberstam hi mr
halberstam i'm a great admirer of yours
and thank you
i've read about half your books and so
i have three questions for you
number one do you have a favorite of
your 17 books
number two apart from the best and the
brightest
which of your books do you think has had
the greatest effect and third since
you're a baseball fan and you've written
about baseball may we have your
prediction on tonight's seventh game of
the world series thank you very much
okay let me see if i can and um well you
know when you ask someone else which of
your books are your favorite is your
favorite it's sort of like you ask
someone of the large family which of
your children do you like best but there
are two books that that probably aren't
as well known that i'm particular i mean
there's a small book i did on rowing
called the amateurs of four single skull
rowers uh rowing and my wife thinks it's
in a way the best book i've ever done i
mean it's whatever it is i just nailed
it and got it and it's a wonderful
look at a an old-fashioned sport with
old-fashioned values sort of a
hermetically sealed world and i really
am very fond of that book and then
there's a book i did called the children
about the civil rights
kids the early first really civil rights
students
in nashville tennessee who became the
leaders of snick and challenged the
the the archaic racist laws of our
country and
um i think that i'm terribly moved by
their courage their loyalty their faith
and i that is a favorite book as well i
mean because it's a book about about
courage and about really about faith and
i i didn't think of myself writing a
book about faith but they really it's
it's very move moving their heroism
among those profiled
are two who went on to careers in
politics yeah well one with great
distinction and one with marginal
distinction
negative distinction john lewis who is
probably was a congressman from georgia
who i met in 1916 when he was probably
about 18 years old and i think is the
best american citizen i've ever met i
mean just i think of john and i think of
the west point motto duty honor country
and then marion barry who later became
mayor of washington and i think
and was this very sweet young man when i
first met him and then became upon
election here i think almost
symbolically corrupt in terms of his
personal behavior and really was a
cataclysmic figure i think for the city
what are the lessons about american
society one can draw from the children
that it is an open society that we can
change that we really can hear the
smaller voices in our society when these
young people
start out
on a
started out to challenge
laws in in nashville in february 1960
that didn't allow them to have a world
wars hamburger they they could shop at
woolworth could not eat a hamburger
right there at their little cafeteria
there um
and nobody was on their side the federal
government the local government the
state governments i mean nobody and
they starting there and gradually
getting victories and then going on the
freedom rides and then challenging
voting
rights that excluded blacks from voting
i mean they gradually turn the entire
country around in a period of five or
six years so i mean i think you it's a
room it's a reminder that you can bring
change and that the powerless can
assault the powerful and if they're if
they have right on their side
occasionally they can win
you just described it as a story of
faith i thought i read in your author's
notes which you so frequently do that
was actually at the time of story about
religion well i think so i mean i think
that they were i mean their faith is a
religious faith i mean they are they
were young they're protestants southern
baptist mostly and there's i mean john i
once asked john lewis how they could do
it in you know the over i mean there
they were without weapons taking on the
ku klux klan the power of the government
in in alabama and mississippi this is
the you know the power of the state
police the the local police i mean
really tough tough people who wanted to
kill them and john said well you know
faith in each other faith um in um jim
lawson and the
minister who taught them so wealth of
faith in our god uh faith that we would
not let each other down and then he had
a very sort of faith in america which up
till then had done so little for our
family you know it really is religious
faith
in america in 2001 is religion that a
strong a factor or could it be in our
society in our current situation well i
think it is for some people i think it
varies i think some you know people take
great sustenance from it i think it's
important at a moment like this i think
when the things that you have
counted on
to work
the strength and security of a society
the material success of the site this
society has been phenomenally
successfully successful material in the
last 40 or 50 years and particularly in
the last
10 or 12 i mean it's just been a stun in
the in the clinton years the the dow
went up 6 000 points more than doubled
when those things are pulled off the
table suddenly you're not as secure as
you thought suddenly the economy seems
softer then you have to find reassurance
and confidence in things that you
perhaps
didn't think were so important
previously and i think a lot of people
will
will
take sustenance from their religion or
their other forms of faith i mean i
think there's secular faith out there i
have a kind of secular faith in
in the processes of this country that we
will by and large do the right thing on
any major event when we put our
attention to it our next question for
you comes from i forgot by the way i
didn't answer the guy's question oh
about the world series seriously i think
it's a great world series i always
thought it would go seven games
and i think it's a column i mean if
you've got chilling on three days rest
versus clements on a little bit more
arrest but schilling's been peaching
better this year than than clemens it's
really about it's a column game and so
it's been a great world series i mean
twice two out in the ninth inning 27th
out and the yankees have had home runs
so i mean i don't know what more i think
it's a success either way if you're if
you're a new york fan winning those
three games in new york against those
odds and two of them in the last in the
ninth inning i mean with the home runs i
mean it's just been a wonderful thing
next question for you comes from
springfield missouri here on the air
yes i wanted to ask mr alverstam on
he
is so successful at doing what i'd call
small profiles of people within books
such as mcgeorge bundy or
robert mcnamara in the best and the
brightest or the chandler family in his
book on the media
does he separate out the profiles or
know that he's going to have to do
certain profiles and separate those out
in his research
and do those kind of separate and fill
them in or does
that just come naturally with the
research
that he does on the book
it's a very good question and it's a
little bit of both
when you do a book the best and the
brightest or uh more recently a war in a
time of peace you're you're trying to
get a narrative you start with a
detective it really begins as a what i
try to do
and i really learned from theodore white
teddy white who did the making of
president in 1960 but that if you're
going to be a non-fiction writer and you
want to try and sell some books or or
make your books valuable and accessible
that you really have to be a good
storyteller i mean it you don't want to
write a book that's accurate and
everybody the reviews say oh this is a
very good accurate book and it's a book
all americans should read and it sits
there unopened on a coffee table
you really don't want that you want to
bring people in so
what was interesting when teddy white
did
the making
of a president in 1960 everybody knew
the outcome
you know that john kennedy had beaten
richard nixon said people said oh god
teddy what are you doing that for when
he was out you know what he was on the
campaign so what are you doing writing a
book about the campaign he said well
everybody's going to know the answer but
he made it a cliffhanger i mean you read
that book and you couldn't wait to see
who's going to win well
i try to do the same thing
with the best advice everybody knew
that we had crossed the rubicon and gone
into vietnam but the question of why so
it was a detective novel who did it and
why now when you do that or even when
you do warrant a time a piece you have a
given you have a question
the country
makes a key decision it hinges so you're
doing the decision making the era the
forces at play the politics but the
people so you do and the narrative
there's a run you know what are the
issues what are some of the other things
that factor in the politics but you're
also always doing the people so when
you're interviewing you're interviewing
trouble some people you interview
exclusively
for biographical stuff x or y you know
you're only seeing they don't know
anything else but they know one of the
players but a lot of times you're doing
both you're getting a narrative of why
they do something that why a decision
was made what the meeting was like but
then you're saying well what was
tony lake like or what was mcgeorge
bundy like or what was dick holbrook
like i mean you're trying to get by so
you're really working at two levels and
then in the old days when you know you
type up your notes now i have someone
who helps me with it i dictate notes and
you cut out the biographical stuff and
you put the stuff on a on say on kosovo
or biographical stuff into one pile and
another so that you you know as you're
writing your book you'll go from an
a narration about how a decision was
made in the forces and then you'll go to
a biographical sketch and then you'll go
back to narration you're trying to learn
and improve your story telling ability
all the time because you want people to
start the book
and finish the book
over the course of 30 plus years of
interviewing first-person actors in many
of the world's great events it would
seem that those interviews
above and beyond the books you produced
would have value are you preserving your
archives yeah all what i do i i
interview now when i did the best and
brightest
and we
as we have discussed earlier in this
broker program i was broke all the time
i mean that was a very hard time because
i was doing that book and you know i did
a little bit of writing on the side did
some lecturing but
ten thousand here even in early nineteen
1970 dollars wasn't wasn't a lot of
money um i typed my notes myself now
when that book did well the one luxury
was i would interview someone writing in
longhand as they say oh no i'd say you
know you're going too fast slow down and
i'd write it down and write it down i'd
go home and i would dictate my notes
into a cassette and then i gave them to
a typist usually a retired got a
wonderful woman named carolyn parker who
types up for me now
and
she types them and then i keep i you
know i have two sets and now when the
and then when the uh when the notes when
the book is done i send all my papers at
boston university and they've got which
is great if you're in a new york
apartment because you'd be up to here in
paper my wife is so grateful gene
halverstem is so grateful to boston
university for getting all that paper
out of our apartment wonderful man named
there named howard godley who sort of
watches over me my papers have been
there for 37 years and my notes go there
and um there's a lovely guy named tom
griffith who uh
was a top editor at time life and he did
a book once on teddy white and harry
loose the
and he went up and he said could he look
at my notes and i said sure and he went
up he came back he said
those are the greatest notes i've ever
seen i mean they're all so careful
they're so well these i had to look at
teddy white's notes and it was like you
know it was chicken scratches and a pad
they are very good notes
why boston
well in 1964 when i came back from
vietnam
and i was
29 years old about to be 30. howard
gottlieb said he would like my papers
and i thought he was kidding and he
said no he was dead serious so i said
sure and i had all my stuff all my notes
and flemish and i gave him to him and
it's i mean he was the first there and
he's been terrific it's accessible they
do a wonderful job he is a great
librarian he's a wonderful charming man
a great boulevardier howard howard
godlieb is and it has been
one of the booms of our lives that we
are not overwhelmed by paper in our
apartment
you can reach david haberstein another
way besides telephone calls we'll also
take email questions for him the address
is book tv at
cspan.org our next phone call comes from
utica new york utica you are on the air
welcome
yes good morning
mr helstein
i'm i'm not a uh a caller of these
programs
my only attempt to prior to this was uh
when mr brookhire's resigned
and then the program was interrupted uh
for the the action uh
beginning to take place in afghanistan
but uh
the question i was going to pose to him
prior to the question i'd like to pose
to you
i i just wonder
what your response might be
his book had to do with george
washington
and uh he was great lover of new york
and came from rochester
and you were a resident of new york
so
um
so many times in our country we put up
beautiful edifices and we put these
wonderful sayings on them
and are they only to decorate the
edifice
or do people take them to heart
so i'm curious as to whether or not
you're familiar with a quote from
george washington on the washington
memorial in
washington park
in washington park
what's the quote caller
it's um
let us raise the standard
to which the good and honest may repair
the matter is in the hands of god
and you think that quote has particular
poignancy now caller
i think it is particularly poignancy
colloids
well let's let's let's hear mr
halperstein's thoughts on that thanks
well i mean i'm a george washington fan
i mean i think it's amazing the more you
put you know when you're young you learn
that he's the father of your [ __ ] the
father of your country and then you sort
of
go away from early american history and
you begin to think well probably there's
a lot of spin and maybe wasn't that
extraordinary and then you go back as a
grown man and start reading about them
and you come away with a sense of
extraordinary qualities of courage and
the ability to sustain
uh
uh an ideal and a difficult time and i
mean strengths
while all kinds of other people were
really letting him down the
the the qualities within were uncommon
so um i don't think it's a bad quote i
think it's pretty good i must say the
day the
the the bombing started when we started
bombing the quote that jumped into my
mind was
from emerson
events are in the saddle and ride
mankind i mean meaning that we had
unpowerful forces had been uncapped in
both sides and would not lightly be
capped again that something very big
tough and fierce was now at play and
could not lightly be stopped you know i
have found that quote in a number of
your books yes you will find that quote
in
it was used by george ball
in uh in 1964 on his dove papers because
he thought that they kept thinking he
was
appalled because they kept thinking they
had options and he was telling them in
fact every day that they didn't stop
this they had fewer options but it's a
very very good quote
next call for use from boston welcome to
the program
oh yes hello um
just have a call for
mr i mean a question from mr albertson
i'm sorry i'm nervous it's okay that's
two of us
um and i'd just like you to comment on
um
some of the attacks that the press
certain reporters have gotten when
they've turned and asked the question in
regards to september 11th uh
what a government um what what they had
been up to or what their foreign policy
was
or they just asked the question why did
these terrorists fly an airplane into
the world trade center
i'd just like to hear your comments on
i know that um there are there have been
some reporters
and uh writers who have been censored by
their um editors or in some cases fired
um because of asking that question
they're turning to our government and
saying hey what's what's going on here
and why are people attacking us
i know that when i was in the military i
was stationed aboard an aircraft carrier
and we shot down two aircraft over libya
and what i read in l.a times
and what i witnessed were two different
things so i just wonder if you
if we're getting uh the reporting and um
as accurately as um
as it should be
because i feel like maybe some of the
reporters are afraid to write or ask
these uh important questions um out of
free of their their job or um
their standing
i i haven't heard of anybody being fired
and i must say i haven't heard of any uh
reporters being you know in effect
threatened by their bosses for being
too critical i i think we are
entering a very
tense time in relationship between
government and
press i mean i think it's always
difficult when there is one of wars on
him i mean vietnam is a very good
example of uh the fact that it didn't
work and the government was saying that
it did work and the reporters were early
on the early dissenters in sense of
saying giving pessimistic appraisals and
we took in that rather
um innocent eretz and much more innocent
than than now we took a lot of heat from
being pessimistic early on i've talked a
little bit about this already
but this one's going to be much harder
because it's an invisible enemy
uh he uses the enemy uses stealth
false uh
identify identities
he lives among us and wants to blow us
up so you can't fight him in a normal
wartime situation so
it brings out i mean therefore you fight
him in a certain way it doesn't lend
itself to an open society so the
government has some legitimate views
about control of information and of
course the press wants to cover at the
same time it doesn't want to be isolated
as looking unpatriotic so every there's
all kinds of political stuff that is at
play here i think it's a very important
time for both sides for the government
and the press to be wise to understand
that it's a new kind of equation i think
it's very important for the government
you know one of the great the one of the
few growth industries in our country in
the last 20 years has been spin all
kinds of people now know how to spend
the most because the media has become so
important the most important thing at
the end of the day was to get your
vision out on television didn't mean
mine even matter if what you were saying
was accurate or true or whatever as long
as you got it out i mean spinning
something giving your side of an event
and your your
rationale for something was more
important this seems to be a very good
time for everybody not to spin
to sort of try and understand that if we
go into a very difficult
confrontation like this
where so little traditional reporting
can be done that our that the
credibility of our government when we
say something it better be accurate
because if it's shown that we're
not telling the truth to the people and
they're dependent on the truth and then
later it turns out it's not true
the credibility of the government will
begin drop and people will not trust
again it's very important
the government's award seems to me in
this moment to be unusually sacred and
they ought to be very respectful of what
they do
because we don't have very easy access
to alternative versions in most cases
the government says one thing if you're
a journalist you can go and talk to
other people you can do a balance now
the government itself has to be aware
that it is really on the spot and to be
very careful
with its use of its credibility
on the journalistic side we've seen a
lot of discussions on the 24-hour news
channels of public soul searching for
reporters about the
equation of being patriotic and
objective in reporting at the same time
what are your thoughts on that well i
think the 24-hour news cycles could all
do with instead of worrying so much
about patriotism and objectivity which i
don't think they've ever i don't think
of
the big stars of the 24-hour news cycles
being terribly worried about
objectivity i see most of them worried
about self-promotion i i think they
ought to worry more about being
intelligent i think they would be
thinking more about putting on people
who know something and not i think one
of the things that's really a problem in
this society is the 24-hour news cycle i
think it's a a giant monster that needs
to eat and eat and eat and chews up
stuff and it it and so there has to be
information even when and there has to
be an event or a pseudo event when
there's not one i mean it's the it's the
it's the uh
the the 24-hour news cycles of those
people who've given us
no small part of the tabloid agenda that
we've had for the last
dozen or so years it's they're the
people who were staking out gary
congressman gary condits house and the
levy house they're the ones who feasted
on the lewinsky thing and made it so
much bigger than it really was i mean
you know drove this thing because it was
something they could get their hands on
and they've really given our agenda
trivialization so i'm i'm i'm not
terribly worried about their new soul
searching about their patriotism i i'd
really like to see them more thoughtful
i i think that we haven't learned i mean
the hunger of any of
of the of the of the news cycles there
and the need to kind of drive something
and to seize on stories that really
would have been smaller stories in
another era but are big stories like the
condit story i mean that's an
interesting story but it wasn't
the
preeminent story of the of several
months the way they drove it but they
liked that kind of tabloid sensational
story
we're spending three hours as david
haverstein talking about his writing
career this is c-span 2's in-depth
series next call for him is from san
francisco you're on the air mr
halberstam i'm curious about the habit
of your writing
for example when you do it what are the
surroundings that allow you focus
and inspiration and how does your habit
differ from being in new york in the
winter versus nantucket good good
question um
well when i first started writing
full-time on books which was 1969 i had
bought a house in nantucket which you
could then do even if you were still a
journalist it wasn't yet the quite the
play bro ground of the dot-com rich or
the wall street rich that it is since
become and uh i did most of my writing
there this is pre
uh computer pre-personal uh computer uh
days and i would try and do my
interviewing
um in the what we call the mainland in
the united states uh and then by the
time so if i got there in june i would
really just be able to sit there for
three or four months writing every day
and then then come off and it'd be a
great thing because i'd
write for four or five hours in the
morning and maybe go fishing in the
afternoon something like that and
so when i left the island after three or
four months i'd have a huge chunk of a
book done and yet i'd feel like i'd had
a vacation
and then in time my wife and i had a
daughter in our schedules changed the
new tyranny of children's schools
appeared we we it turned out we hadn't
air conditioned our apartment we just
when we built it we hadn't you know
because we were if it was hot we were in
nantucket we had to redo our apartment
and put in central air conditioning and
and you begin to adapt your writing
schedule more more of it was in new york
and and it was adapted to to family
needs but the key and and the key thing
though is is a schedule being sort of
brutal about it i mean nantucket was
easier because there are fewer
distractions in your sort of fewer
pressures on you but in new york i would
get up usually around you know i get up
now we have dogs and for time one before
our daughter went off um you know have
breakfast with her
and then i would try and be writing by
about nine o'clock and i would try and
write for four or five hours and that's
a long day and then i would be
and then take the rest of the day off
you just were rolling some pictures of
you at work in your office and it it
looks a a little filled with paper yeah
it's um somebody i when i i once worked
next to when i was on the new york times
a a wonderful and that's the robert
kennedy award for book i got that for
the children john lewis and i think both
won that year uh that's some books in
the back there i think there's my friend
michael arlen's book an american verdict
but you've got your own system for
organizing all yeah this this this
organization is uh is uh is is
triumphant in my
uh in my house uh i i i sat next to cp
true cell when i was briefly on the new
york times and in 1961
pect trusell was an old-timer and he'd
been with truman the day truman the day
roosevelt died and he once looked at me
and said you're a one-man slum i mean
lovely i mean i'm a great accumulator of
paper
that's just those are the bookshelves on
the left are all my own books and then
at the top are those there's a nantucket
uh
ship there that's the harvard crimson
mug that you get with your name on it so
that's at least
50 years old you know
next call for use from fairbanks alaska
well thank you very much brother this
heats man is just fantastic
my question to uh david uh
is uh
in the situation we have in afghanistan
today
uh can you
can you see any other alternative we
would have rather
than bombing these people uh
i guess i'm
kind of concerned that we are
going to kill a lot of people there and
uh
i mean some of them you want to kill
probably but
i mean it'd be like
children kids uh
little you know people that
are going to die
either through the starvation that may
come up from the lack of food
can you see any alternative i don't i i
mean i you know that as i say the day
the bombing began i had a melancholy
feeling of and i used that phrase from
emerson events are in the saddle and
ride mankind and i
you sat there thinking you know what
alternatives are there and i didn't
think so i think it's hard i don't think
the taliban is particularly vulnerable
to true to traditional weaponry that we
have i think we have to do it i think we
have to set them back i don't have great
faith in the military abilities of the
northern alliance i
perhaps they'll do better and i think
bombing is is a somewhat
crude instrument in a situation like
that and that they are because of the
way the taliban function in caves and
probably moving among the population and
some of the cities and uh moving into
mosques and moving into hospitals and
things like that it's going to be
extremely hard i have no illusion that
is easy i have no illusion that you in
doing this may end up doing some of
their recruiting for them even as you
are momentarily military successful if
you know something about vietnam you
knew that sometimes your military
success has also worked for the other
side and it allowed them to do their
recruiting ice but i don't see much
alternative to this
your latest book warranted time of peace
is really a study of the
success of tactical air strikes in it
worked very well in serbia i mean the
new high precision of
bombing is really pretty brilliant and
if there is a traditional target and the
serbs in the kosovo
campaign did give us a number of targets
and we i mean we were able to take out
bridges and and we did things there that
people didn't think could be done by
bombing in fact it was the most i mean
people like myself who had always been
skeptical about what air power could do
alone i mean vietnam certainly would
make you that
i mean i always understood that air
power could be very well be effective in
a tactical sense and that is if you are
fighting an enemy and you have air power
over the battlefield shooting at their
tanks or whatever that's attack air and
that that's a great asset but in
strategic air
both in korea and in vietnam uh there
were great limits to it because the the
terrain and the enemy the enemy was such
that he was able to either work at night
or in thick foliage use tunnels in
vietnam so the strategic bombing never
was as effective as as its
as as its fans proclaimed
what's really true is i mean people like
me
who had doubts about air power were
really
wrong i mean just to be blunt i was
wrong about the effectiveness of air
power in in in kosovo it was much more
effective than i would have thought let
me ask you a quick story before the next
call it was struck reading about someone
you call me or is nicknamed by
colleagues mad john ward he's the
architect of this new modern campaign
and it demonstrates sometimes that small
circumstances can have big consequences
you write that he normally wouldn't have
been given the job of creating the
campaign but his superior who was more
conventional was on leave was on leave
and they didn't like him he was really
sort of a renegade a maverick and he had
the idea that you could take modern air
power that it was so accurate and
precise it would be like taking and
particularly obviously the more
developed the society the more effective
it is i don't think it's very defective
against the taliban in afghanistan but
it would be effective against serbia and
to enter iraq that instead of getting
into a really conventional traditional
war you could use the bombing almost
like taking a hyperdermic needle and
freezing the nervous system of an of
an enemy you could take out the
communications take out the military
communications you could really freeze
the system and isolate its forces in the
field and we did precisely that in in
the gulf war i mean so that by the time
the ground war started it was a defeated
army really i think uh and and it was
john warden who was the architect of
this and i think it's quite a brilliant
it's it's really something well worth
reading about because i spent a lot of
time on it because i was so surprised by
the accuracy of what he came up with
next question for you comes from little
falls new york
yes first of all i'd like to thank mr
haberstrom for most of his books that i
have read and i would also like to
suggest some new ones
number one no journalist has written yet
that ronald reagan's use of the word
liberal in such a pejorative way
that today you almost have to prove you
are patriotic if you say you are liberal
it sounds like they're saying communist
and the effect that this has had on free
speech
on the kind of columnists that are
allowed on the kind of talk shows that
we have
this needs to be written because it has
done more damage than mccarthyism did
number two
and
we need a look powers that be too
at the control of the media by the
conservatives it is even worse than what
i read in your book
at the time
number three the election results as a
patriotic american i was more depressed
by what happened in florida than i was
by the kennedy assassination
that was serendipity this went to the
heart of our democratic system i'm a
college professor and i teach that votes
overcome money votes overcome power and
they didn't and the last one why have we
not heard that a consortium of
newspapers
got the university of chicago to do a
research study that this study was
supposed to be released september 17th
and they are holding it back for
supposedly patriotic reasons or it might
cause too much difficulty for the
country thank you that's a lot to work
with
the last one is on the election outcome
i just i in fact i heard that in fact
that the consortium um had more or less
shown that uh
that bush won but i'm not really
aware of it uh jeffrey tubin by the way
is a very talented young writer
has written has just written a book on
the florida election and i presume it is
he's done awfully good work in the past
so i presume he's done it with his usual
excellence i mean there's no doubt two
things one there is no doubt that the
surge of
the reagan years and the conservative
movement in the country did seem to make
the word liberal seem pejorative i think
that that's come back a little bit i
think the pendulum
in our politics swings back and forth
and i think the caller's right in in one
sense i mean that the the you if you
were doing
the powers that be which i did in came
out 22 years ago is a very it would be a
very different book because the power is
very fragmented but there's no doubt
that the power in the media and the
coming of large corporations i don't
think that there's so much concern i
don't think if it's a liberal
conservative
struggle but i think it is a
trivial serious
struggle i think the networks have
become infinitely more trivial in the
ensuing 20 years and is really because
the
proprietarial generation that i wrote
about in the networks people i mean
whatever their flaws and they were not
inconsiderable paley and sarnoff have
been replaced by people that are giant
corporations the only thing they care
about is the stock they look at the
bottom line and they find it oh foreign
correspondence well that's expensive and
we don't get much out of them and no one
cares about foreign policy the ratings
are down but oh a good trivial report
about a hollywood celebrity well that's
terrific it's not expensive and so what
you've gotten is i think a decreasing
quality of serious journalism out of the
networks i mean real scandal i think
because they've gotten rid of all their
foreign correspondents and they started
rewarding what i would call the feather
emergency the male and female divas of
artificial empathy who can who have
access to hollywood celebrities and
you know people in the condit case or
the lewinsky case that's become the big
thing and it's because it drives the
rating it's not liberal conservative
it makes money and so we have as a kind
of journalism that you start out and
it's it's not good journalism it but
it's good for the ratings which is good
for the stock and i think bad for the
country it's one of the reasons why we
were partially asleep on september 11th
we'd we'd binged as a country not
looking in terms of being self-absorbed
and not paying attention to the rest of
the world you criticized the networks
did the same sort of thing happen to
major newspapers but much less so um
certainly not the washington post and
the new york times or the wall street
journal's news branch
la times was i think in trouble because
you had a managerial generation although
it's getting better again and all kinds
of papers across the country are not
nearly as good as they used to be
because they're owned by
large companies corporations night
raiders gotten much much worse uh than
it used to be uh the level of journalism
has gone down because they're trying to
drive a tony ridder that's trying to
drive the stock up and the norms of the
stock are are diminishing the quality of
the journalism manhattan is our next
caller for you welcome
yeah hello this is the question for
david hoverstein my name is xavier
warlands
uh mr halperstein
actually it's helbersdam
david as a european living in in
manhattan one of the things that shocked
me most
was uh the perception of the president
when all the events saying that he was
really uh stoned about uh shocked about
the reaction and that abroad they had
towards america and the hatred of
america
and um
and this lack of perception of of having
being traveled around the world
it's it's it's really concerning because
if the president really
was discovering this new
this new face
of reality that me traveling abroad i
have felt for so long and my american
friends traveling too
um
how how can you address this this lack
of historical knowledge well i think
it's a been an insular time in america
and the president himself was her when
he ran and was elected he's not anymore
maybe but he was a reflection of that
insularity he had never traveled he'd
been to mexico and i guess he'd visit
his father in china when his father was
the country had turned inward i think it
goes back to the
end of the cold war i mean i think we've
always been essentially isolationist uh
i think to understand america you have
to understand our geography the the
impact of the two oceans and the sense
that we are separated from the rest of
the world and we quite like it that way
by the way
and then that changed at the end of
world war ii for a variety of reasons
one the generation that had fought the
war had paid had seen the price paid for
the calamitous quality of the
isolationism in addition they'd lost
their friends their college roommates
and in addition the weaponry had changed
at the end of the war we'd come up with
the atomic bomb and the germans had come
up with rockets and that was obviously
and the oceans became ponds but when as
the cold war began to wind down
as the
as the uh the threat from the soviet
union began to diminish and ended in the
soviet union collapsed
the um
the oceans became ponds uh again i mean
ponds be the ponds became oceans we felt
more protected again we felt
invulnerable in the world and we binged
on self-absorption so we didn't know
what the rest of the world felt and we
had to understand that if you are a
monopoly superpower if the russians are
no longer a threat
that um that the rest of the world now
has an excuse to not like you that
nobody roots for goliath will chamber
when we will change when the basketball
player who was seven feet tall everybody
whoever he went except at his home court
everybody booed him because as he said
no one roots for goliath
we've gotten a number of interesting
questions by email i'm going to try to
work those in between calls here's one
it's from bonnie lincoln watching us in
fort myers florida who writes when
robert mcnamara revealed recently he had
known the vietnam war was unwinnable but
pursued it anyway this seemed to provoke
two basic reactions relief and
gratification that he had finally told
the truth and in effect vindicated the
anti-war movement and outraged that he
had continued to sacrifice lives to a
lost cause what was your take well i
think the latter feeling in general was
much more powerful i don't think there
was much relief that this man who had
been such a forceful player and had
remained silent for so long i mean
everybody knew he'd had doubts but he'd
been so deeply disingenuous for more
than 30 years that i think the rage on
the part of most people that he now was
coming to the table with this very badly
done book very dishonest book that he
wrote then i think there was mostly rage
i didn't see much relief i think there
was a real ray it was like tearing open
a scar that had finally begun to heal
you almost tear it open again
the book was so dishonest because he
says you know finally first he's silent
for 30 years which is unacceptable i
mean he was a player he owed us and his
crimes there were never war crimes i
don't believe in war crimes but he and
bundy the crime of silence while this
debate was taking place here's a man who
by february 1966 believed the war was
unwinnable
and remained silent i mean i think that
is
truly shocking in a free society but one
of the things he says in there there's a
sentence i forgot he used to know what
page it was on page 39 isn't it says we
none of us
mac bundy dean russ the president me
maxwell taylor could ever get the
information we wanted i thought i read
that and i thought you son of a [ __ ]
you you're still lying because he was
more than anyone else
the person who beheaded the messengers
who brought them bad news i mean i saw
it i witnessed it i was a victim of it
myself it started as early as 1962.
when a desmond fitzgerald who is the
father of francis fitzgerald the writer
desmond fitzgerald i think was the
number three person in the
cia who went and
briefed him once a week and desmond
fitzgerald goes over to um um the brief
him and mcnamara's asking how many you
know quantified how many of this how
many of that how many of them are on the
internet and finally does mr joseph you
know mr mr secretary i don't think these
numbers mean much you know i don't think
so and
what do you mean well i just think i
have a bad feeling about it doesn't
smell right out there i mean i
and the meeting is almost immediately
called over i mean terminates the
meeting and as desmond fitzgerald is
walking across this large office
mcnamara says to his secretary in a very
loud voice i never want that man to
brief me again
okay scene two john vann whom both neil
sheehan and i wrote about uh at great
length uh in this in the summer of 63
he's on his he's come home in fact he
and i'm writing pessimistically there
he's giving pessimistic briefings at
ever higher levels in the pentagon in
fact they almost court martial because
they think he's the source of my stories
even though i haven't seen him in a
couple of months
he's supposed to in to brief the
joint
chiefs on a given morning and he shows
up and everything starts and hairs back
and he's there with the the master
sergeant who's in charge of it the phone
rings the master sergeant picks up the
phone system
starts it listens he says now let me get
this right
the chairman
of the joint chiefs and the secretary of
defense want that item
stricken
from the agenda
yes
i want to get straight both yes
turns to van says
looks like you don't brief today buddy
it was mcnamara and max taylor who
struck out
crossed off the dissenting pessimistic
warning
third scene and then i can give you 20
more
uh it's the fall it's about october 1963
in vietnam
neil and i and all the other reporters
are clued in the wars being lost
henry cabot lodge mcnamara's over there
henry cabot lodge is the ambassador he
asks us to talk to mcnamara about how
the war is going i don't think reporters
should brief public officials
but lodge had helped us get access on
helicopters so we agreed to do it
if we go into this meeting
four or five of us all go on to win the
pulitzer prize by the way
mcnamara turns and the rules are
suddenly explained we cannot talk about
the military status
we can only talk about the political
status that means he can go back to
washington and say when he gets home
that he didn't hear anyone say that the
war wasn't going well
all the way through in those years he
was cutting off the heads of anybody who
tried to descend so for him to say that
we could never get the information i
think he's the biggest lying son of a
[ __ ] that this country ever produced in
government
i hate that book
and he gets away with it i mean he
doesn't get away no he didn't get away
with it but he thought he could get away
with it
next call for you is wilsonville oregon
go ahead
uh mr halberstamp uh you authored uh
uh the breaks of the game you know in
1981 uh season with the portland
trailblazers
uh sir i have a question uh involving uh
bill walton
sir did you have an opportunity to
discuss walton's foot problems
with dr bob cook his physician
and uh if so
were you given an ex explanation by him
on why
walton allowed their close friendship to
end in anger and bitterness over his
perception
uh on the way he was treated
well i did like you know that's a very
painful moment because bob cook the
doctor and bill walton had been very
close friends uh bill was a great
athlete he had uh this extraordinary
body and ability but he had sort of your
grandmother's feet and eventually his
feet broke down he did take a shot the
shot turned out to be catastrophic for
him
and real bitterness grew out of that and
what had been once a very good
relationship with bob cook ended
you know i have a question
from
by email that would be a nice follow-on
to that let me see if i can find it real
quickly it's a viewer who writes and
this is a new yorker
who writes why do you have a serious
interest in spectator sports which i
find quite childish please give us a
philosophical response and not the usual
empty sentimentality
this is charles thomas of new york
well i mean
i enjoy the sports it's a great window
on american society i mean if you want
to know what television has done to our
society how it's changed its effect the
effect of the money that it brings in
how it changes value systems
the changes in authority i mean for
instance
sports where once owners were all
powerful now athletes are all powerful
sports were managers or coaches once
we're all powerful and where
the athletes are all powerful you know
if you want to understand change levels
of authority and finances you better
look first at sports you can understand
it better the effect of television on on
any number of institutions you can
understand it more readily in sports in
addition if you want to understand race
in america
you do well to understand sports it's a
great window on society i mean i did a
book summer of 49 which was on a
a season in
a baseball pen
in in 1949 and it was a great window on
an america
that no longer existed because in that
day it was
a total of only 16 teams a southern team
was washington a western team was st
louis the teams played in the daytime
they traveled by train
the teams were almost entirely white
uh
i mean
you know if you made the owners had
all-powerful player didn't like this
this contract the owner sent him all he
had to do was you know retire that was
his alternative he couldn't trade
himself he couldn't hold out i mean so
you take that and you jump ahead to
1989 or the year 2000 and you get a
sense of how dramatically the society
has changed so it's a great great window
i enjoy it
writers unlike academics
do not get sabbaticals i mean
we don't get every seventh year off i
mean i have to write every day i have to
do legwork every day so one of the nice
things that happened it began with the
portland book was in addition to what
are allegedly serious books that i do on
politics and the society i do these
sports books about
every third book or so is a book on
sports they're great fun i meet people
that i like that enriches me it cat i'm
allowed it's a little bit less
pressurized so i enjoyed it sort of a
bit of a sabbatical graham green used to
do this he'd write these very serious
novels and then he'd write what he
called entertainments which were
detective novels these are my these are
my entertainments and uh i've enjoyed
them they've enriched me greatly i've
made some wonderful friends and i've
learned i mean if you wanna i've learned
a lot i mean if you wanted to understand
how cable society changed the coming of
cable television changed america i mean
doing my michael jordan book was the way
to do it i mean the creation of a
celebrity culture begins with the coming
of the cable uh networks
that book is playing for keeps michael
jordan in the world he made
next call is from oxford mississippi
hey
hi dr mr stam yeah hi
um
i have a question about uh october 64
your book on baseball
uh
did that book do well and uh
if so uh are you planning on doing
another one similar to that for a
later team later season well
it did well uh the the first book on
baseball uh summer 49 just did
phenomenally well i think it's it's you
know still selling very well it was
number one it was interesting i did one
book on baseball uh
summer 49 that was the number one
bestseller in the new york times and
then one book on how we went to war in
vietnam that was also number one on the
new york times list so i had these two
books that couldn't be more different
that went to the top of that you know to
the mountaintop um and october 64 did
well not quite as well but it was a very
good bestseller and it got out there and
people enjoyed reading it i don't know
i'll do more sports books i don't know
if i'll do another baseball book i'm
just not sure at this moment i don't
want to push this too much but as i was
preparing for our conversation it struck
me a bit that just in the past two weeks
michael jordan's back playing baseball
yankees are in the series
a ford has taken over at ford motor
company
uh the united states is fighting in a
war against uh people with hundreds of
years of history and it's being covered
in an extensive way by the media it
seems like all of your subject matter my
my friend russell baker was a wonderful
colleague and was long-time new york
times reporter and columnist talking
about the new book warrant time piece
and being very generous about it said
that he thought it caught the arc of my
career that all the other things that
i've been doing in these previous 45
years
somehow got into the book i mean
covering america covering overseas
covering vietnam going all over the
world all these experiences which have
enriched me i think and also each other
the other books that i've done
because when i do my larger book it's
each one is like going off to get a
separate graduate degree they take four
or five years so it's almost like on the
first day of the book you're knocking on
the it's an education within itself
you're knocking on the door of a new
graduate school and saying let me in
i'll come here for four or five years
i'll try and master this subject whether
it's foreign policy or the media or
competition with the japanese from the
1950s and in four or five years i'll
graduate and i'll give you this book as
a
i mean so all these things i've been
paid to learn
for
you know it's 46 years since i graduated
from college so i've had this wonderful
career where i've been learning and i
think my work has gotten richer and more
complicated because i've
encompassed so much in the process of of
doing all this
next calls from boston go ahead uh yes i
i want to thank c-span first i think
you're doing an incredible job for this
country uh i'd agree with that too
because there aren't many other outlets
where
a serious writer can get a a chance to
have a hearing these days in this
society mostly if you're a writer and
you get on television you're on for
about a minute and a half
and uh and you better have a book that
either is a book about how dieting or
something like that or how to be your
own best friend or something like that
it's got to be a feel-good book or a
diet book it seems to me
i concur a few quick points and then
i'll uh hang up and listen for mr
halverstein uh first i i just finished
rasheed's taliban and uh karen
armstrong's islam
and uh
i would like to hear something about i
was shocked by the this uh what's going
to happen at the end with the oil
consortiums
when this war is over what what uh role
will they play in the reshaping of
afghanistan uh another point is i i
think it can't be expressed enough
that there was a judicial coup in this
country i'd like to hear something about
that
and um what about this i consider a
major fraud by fox television network
being perpetrated against this country
calling themselves fair and balanced
but uh as far as taliban and i have this
mental picture of this one-eyed cave
dwelling mr omar at a five-star hotel in
houston with bush's oil buddies seems
incredible to me talk about that i'll
hang up thank you
well on the taliban and oil it seems to
me that one of the things we should be
thinking about is long range and we
should be thinking about our long-range
security it seems to me that one of the
things that we've learned in the last
two months is that our alleged allies i
mean even those in the
nations in in the middle east that are
supposedly allies whether it's egypt or
the saudis they're not really allies in
a very in any strong sense i mean the
egyptians whisked bin laden's family out
of here without our approval they have
not been cooperative and to our
intelligence agencies who are pursuing
the uh
the roots and the connections of the 11
saudi nationals who were part of the
september 11th uh
bombings they've been in no way
cooperative and and this is you know
american security is there and i think
we should be thinking long term about i
mean here it is push is coming to shove
this is a very tough time for us and
they're not being cooperative so we
should be thinking in the long range
about being less dependent on middle
eastern oil for the sake of our children
for our security we should not have so
much
invested
in terms of national security on people
who really aren't very sympathetic to us
and aren't there when it matters so it
seems to me that some kind of discipline
change in energy use maybe taxes
that will get us to be more disciplined
in our energy use is something that
should be really right at the front of
the table now so that in the future we
will have a great deal more independence
from those in the middle east who turned
out not to be terribly reliable that
would be
the first thing that comes to my mind
his second question was calling the
election results a judicial coup well i
think i mean i don't think it's it's not
a great election
it got down there to a cliffhanger and
if you're in a cliffhanger and one party
controls the
hierarchy
the republican party i mean if it had
been in new york or you know it's been
in a state that the democrats had
controlled everybody be cheering the
democrats to be cheering it happened to
be a state where the
brother of one of the candidates was the
governor and he controls the state
operating political operation and the
democrats paid for it i mean they paid
for it they were obviously very careless
in terms of the preparation of the
ballot um and in checking out who was
allowed to vote that was obviously a
mistake but the truth is that al gore
did not run a really very good campaign
i mean that was that was the real
problem and that was what was mostly at
stake in that election i don't think of
it as a judicial coup i mean i think
it's heartbreaking election for for gore
um and for the democrats and you know
i'm sure there are people who feel that
way i just think you have to you know
it's a free society you have these
elections there's probably been things
like that before the results are in
they're painful and hard to take and
then you get on with it because this
country can't stop and look backward
next calls from new york city
mr halberstam i have great respect for
your work i served as a rifle platoon
leader in both the 101st airborne
division and another unit but i have
great respect for you then as well what
uh time period thank you uh this was 72
717 that's a very tough time too because
the war is winding down it's post-tet
and it's really ugly i mean you're out
there and it's not going to work and the
other side's really strong and it's it's
like
being on a vigil when everybody else is
pulling up and leaving am i right
it was uh my question though is i read
mcmaster's book their election of duty
it's a great book it's a great show
bright
david carter's broken vietnam
and i i don't understand your position
on war crimes i mean clearly the
military leaders
uh committed the dereliction of duty
which is a crime the tonkin gulf fraud
was a criminal act and yet it's not
prosecuted should we just forget about
this and allow them to continue doing it
i mean eisenhower warned us about the
military-industrial complex
i'll listen to your answer thank you
thank you well first off
when i talk about war crimes i mean more
crimes in the
nuremberg sense i mean i mean i don't
believe in this i think these people
made catastrophic
mistakes and miscalculations and lied
and continued that's why i'm so bitter
about mcnair because i think his book is
deeply disingenuous i mean first off
that long period of silence
if he's going to come out with a book at
the end he really has to do a much more
honest book and i'm enough of a witness
to know
that he's lying the book that he
mentions one of the most important is a
book he calls a dereliction of duty is
by a young army major he's probably not
a major anymore h.r mcmaster and it is
if you think i'm devastating in the best
and brightest about people like
mcnamara and maxwell taylor he is
approaching he has much more access to
certain material than i and it is a book
that has great resonance among military
men because it really colin powell for
example it shows how the joint chiefs
and the
and the chair and the head of the
secretary of defense played the
political game for lyndon johnson at the
expense of the military men in vietnam
it is a devastating book
i don't believe as i say in war crimes i
think we i think i i'm
moved that you've read these wonderful
books my colleague neil sheehan's
brilliant book bright shining light i
think we should learn we should read we
should pay attention i think it's
important to read the mcmaster book but
uh and i think you've you know you've
done it well and uh
and we shouldn't lightly forget how
leadership can really take care of
itself and be uh and be really deeply
disingenuous not only what it's doing
but then fair failed to be candid after
it's really
a catastrophe
we are halfway through a three-hour
conversation with david halberstam about
his writing career you can telephone us
numbers that will be on the screen
throughout our conversation or you can
send us an email at the halfway mark can
we get some more water is this
possibility we don't want to part you as
you're talking here uh and you can send
us an email at booktv cspan.org next
call is from san francisco
yes my name is scott bastival and i
believe
uh should be required reading for your
books that people want to understand our
country and culture but i was curious if
you had a favorite word and perhaps you
could share some of your favorite
authors that you've enjoyed over the
years well i've loved the the writings
of graham greene over the years i mean
um his books i think he's always been
just a wonderful writer one of the best
books of um
on vietnam was the quiet american which
i used to reread about once a year
i was thrilled when vs knight paul won
the nobel prize i think he's a great
great writer and particularly about the
underdeveloped world of the third world
i was once for the new york times a
correspondent
in the congo uh and so like witnessed
events there and naipaul wrote a great
book about the congo bend in the river
which is well worth reading i mean he's
just an amazing talent
uh when i was young teddy white's book
john gunther's books were inspirational
you know people don't know john gunther
today you know and he would do these
inside america or inside africa he's a
great reporter and he would just vacuum
information and his stuff is never out
of date
uh
when i was young there was a book called
the reason why by cecil woodham smith on
why the reason the the light brigade
marched into the valley of death and
when i read that it sort of made me want
to write comparable books because i read
like a great novel and i mean i just
they're all i just finished reading a
wonderful book
by a man named charles baxter
it's called he's a professor he's a it's
not it's a work of fiction he teaches at
the university of michigan and
it's called a feast of love it's just
beautifully done lyrical book i i mean i
just enjoyed it so much there just
there's so much good writing out there
now i mean they're so it's interesting
there's so many talented people out
there writing better and better and
there's so little of a bit ventilated
into the modern media process for
whatever reason in the children you
reference a book called the american and
american dilemma yeah oh boy
that's a great book that's a
i had graduated from college in 1955 and
remember i'm someone who graduates
without honors i'm i'm not a great
student i'm a bad student i think i'm in
the bottom third of my class and it's
it's intellectually i'm having a hard
time and i go off to mississippi and a
young lady i know gives me a copy of
gunnar murdoch's
american dilemma an american dilemma
which upon which really the supreme
court decision of 54 was
based and there i am in a small town 10
000 people 8 000 people in mississippi
and i'm working every day out there on
the street covering people and talking
to people and then at night i'm reading
30 or 40 or 50 pages of myrtle and it's
wonderful
it's beautifully written and it's that
great thing that happens if you're a
reporter what you see out in front of
you connects to a book that you're
reading the book
the book gives an intellectual and
historical background
to what you're seeing in daily life that
synergy of life and history comes
together and i thought oh this is
wonderful and it so informed me and it
so enriched me and it was just it was a
pivotal book in my life i mean i later
was able to write to mr murdoch's
daughter who was married to uh
to the president of harvard i mean just
how much that book had meant to me i
mean and that and it gave me the
beginnings of my own intellectual growth
that i didn't have to just only be a
reporter that you could
that you could go and connect to works
of history and it turned out
it was intellectually very important for
me as susan because
i'm not
good intellectually in the abstract
but if you put me out where events are
happening i will devour books and at
least i did that now i'll devour a bit
more in the abstract and it was just
wonderful that i could go to this place
and suddenly have a hunger for learning
and
probably a book that i might not have
been able to read had i been back in
college you might not have kept but it
connected to events and out of that
began my own real intellectual growth
our next call for you is from north
andover massachusetts you're on for
david howard stan well good afternoon
and again thank you c-span i i just
appreciate this so much every every week
and every month when you have the
in-depth
uh susan you do a great interview mr
halberstein i agree hi green yes thank
you it's three different uh quick
questions one did you ever have any
connections in your new york time with
buffalo new york do you have relatives
there no i i don't really
do you have any other children besides
the beautiful little girl that we saw on
the um on the photograph that you
mentioned no i don't but thank you for
the kind
and the other question is do you believe
that creative people when you're
mentioning your time at harvard
creative students
are
but done a disservice by having some of
these standardized tests that
um you know are so important for their
future
and
don't show the creative side of the
human being um because the standardized
standardized testing is for you know
more of a
focused
serious individual who does just student
work
it's a very good point you make out i
don't think it does a disservice i think
sometimes those of us who
aren't
up to speed intellectually or have as i
did
a learning disability which i didn't
know as a learning disability i mean i
didn't
i didn't reckon we didn't know i never
heard the word dyslexia until i was in
my late 30s and this wasn't dyslexia i'm
not dyslexic but i had clearly some kind
of problem with my concentration and and
might still have it um i think people
like that who are not up to speed or
struggle sometimes can define themselves
as not being as smart as they are they
may be talented
but they're not and then there's another
person who's just you know academic work
is just a piece of cake that's like
eating salted peanuts they're very good
they get
high grades they go to college they're
magna with highest honors assuming
but they don't have the originality that
turns into talent and we don't know when
we graduate from college we don't know
who's really talented we don't know
who's going to be original i mean
occasionally we do i mean i was at
college with john updike and he was a
summa [ __ ] laude and he was even then he
was the great uptight but a lot of times
people who are creative are in fact
people who don't get
good marks because they're combative
they're outside they fight conventional
things and their talents going to take
a lot of time to show up most
talented creative people that i know
don't get terribly good marks when
they're young
next question for you is about this book
small book and the writer of this
question says i've been a student of
yours for the past few years in
absentia and in my opinion one of your
best works was your biographical project
on ho very to the point and
uncomfortable to learn the greatness of
the man in retrospect
can you compare the type of
misunderstanding that the u.s had toward
ho his motives in ideology with the
still evolving notions we have toward
the terrorist organizations such as the
taliban and the symbolic figurehead bin
laden
that's a really interesting question the
book is a small
distilled essay on vietnam vietnamese
nationalism with
a small portrait of the life of ho chi
minh in other words i fed his his life
and fed the nationalism into it's very
slim it came out i believe in 1969 i was
as vietnam deep in the book i'd brought
out in 1965 making of a quagmire seemed
to me inadequate it was written when we
had about 18 000 americans there and
about this the time i started doing this
it were about 500 000 and i felt i
hadn't
done it well enough i was dissatisfied
with my own
with my own work and so i had learned
more and i struck and i did this little
essay and i by then i might my his my
history of vietnam was much more up to
speed and this is a good small i think
valuable book it's not a big book or a
rich book but i think it's a
valuable smart book and we had
at least our government had demonized ho
i think ho could have been an ally of
ours i think he admired the united
states and what we had and i you know he
was a communist but he was much more a
nationalist we could have had a
tito a like person there as george
cannon kept
pointing out
i think it's
very different with bin laden i mean i i
think he's
very talented very rich and from day one
he is for a variety of reasons sworn to
our destruction
and he's clever it would be a great
mistake to underestimate him i
i think he's
i don't think it's about israel i think
it's about
not limp it's about limiting our power
in the middle east particularly in d
thereby destabilizing these moderate
allegedly moderate arab arab nations
egypt uh
and saudi arabian countries like that
and putting in islamic fundamentalist
governments there i think he would be a
big power broker i think he's driven by
a passion a ferocity of
narrow viewpoint and ability a skill and
a lot of money and so far a skill in
projecting his ideas
to
some of the miserable of the earth i
mean one of the things that's very
important in this equation
that we don't entirely understand the
effect of is the importance of modern
television
and how it
heightens
tensions between us and that part of the
world
because people who are really miserable
in these terrible countries which have
not modernized turn on television sets
some of them and they see us being rich
and they see themselves being poor
and they make the judgment that they are
poor because we are rich which i think
is great
mistake they're poor because they're
poorly governed because they're
governments for a variety of religious
cultural reasons fight modernity fight
science and technology uh
and uh fight um
educational opportunity i mean they they
are burdened by their own i believe
cultural blinders in in many parts of
the world i think that's why they're
poor they're not poor because we're rich
but
the ability of bin laden to sell the
idea
that they are poor and miserable because
we are rich has been a great great
source of strength to him and this is
going to be a very difficult long
confrontation it's not going to be easy
it's way away from the strengths of the
magnetic field of our power militarily
and in terms of intelligence the prop i
think it's i think would be a mistake to
think that the propaganda war which
we're doing very poorly with can be
readily righted i think for a variety of
reasons it's always going to be a very
hard kind of cell that we're going to
make on our better side to them i think
that we have to assume that we're out
there pretty much alone and we're going
to go into the face of a negative
cultural
social attitude towards us and it's
going to be and if you put up the best
programming in the world with the
smoothest spin doctors trying to sell
american ideas and attitudes and why
what we're doing to that part of the
world it will be it'll be like really
going into a storm i think it's going to
be very tough
pueblo colorado good afternoon
mr halverston i'm much appreciating your
comments thank you
i'm concerned with the current terrorism
crisis
i see a thousand years of confrontation
conflict and animosity
between islam
and western civilization
my question has a western bias
but it can the converse has an islamic
bias question
what aspects
of western civilization and culture
must islam
accept
to ameliorate
this animosity and confrontation or
conversely
what must we in the western civilization
accept from islam
to ameliorate the present confrontation
it's a very interesting question and
it's
possibly
unanswerable
i mean i i think what we have to have
is respect for each other
and
an intelligent opinion of each other i
think
and that may i mean we're we're
certainly not very good at understanding
islam or that part of the world i mean
if you look at
our portrayal of the arab world in our
movies i mean it is really a cartoon i
mean we're if you thought we were bad on
asians back in the 50s and 60s i mean if
you want cartoon view of the world see
how hollywood and others portray the
arab world i mean really it is and over
a very long period of time and i think
we i mean so we start
well behind the curve i think because
we're an open society
we can improve i think it's going to be
harder there because i think the
propaganda wars the lack of a free
society it is these are effectively
closed societies and the whether from
government or
semi-government-sponsored sources the
anti-western
propaganda is ferocious
um the one thing i think we do have
working for us particularly with some
people in that part of the world is and
i mentioned
that they see us now
i think there's a lot of our society
that is very attractive i mean to the
young i mean
the informality of it i mean the way we
treat each other i think i think one of
the great
issues that is at stake here and is not
talked about is
treatment of women i think one of the
reasons that the people who hate us hate
us is
the importance and the rise and the
change in gender in this society the
role of women i think they when they
tune on a television
station and it's cnn and a young woman a
reporter is asking a tough question of
an older white male who's a public
figure and being fearless that is
startling to them and they don't like it
they don't like the i think they see
tellers and they don't like the role of
women in our society and i think that
that's one of the great
blocks in changing that their view of us
and getting them to accept that we have
things that are attractive i i think
there's a real collision out there and i
think the fact that lines are drawn now
means it's not like i don't think we're
likely to get better about them and i
don't think they're likely to get better
about us
next call is from st louis
hi mr halberson uh great to talk to you
i run an educational website on
studying the vietnam war using books and
i highly recommend
best and the brightest it's a
brilliantly rich book uh wonderfully
written thank you i have a question
you in that book you do not reference
make any uh references or end notes
which you explain why you do that and
all your later books
are you you have you do have detailed
references you mentioned mcmasters
great book which is unbelievably
detailed reference i wonder if you have
a
could tell me how the
the nature of book writing on the
vietnam war has changed in terms of
almost requiring such extremely detailed
references
to uh document their resources well i
think it's not so much that it requires
it but it's available now i mean we're
now
[Music]
we're now
26 years since the last american troops
left
were 36 years since the critical
decisions to go in and combat
incarnation
were made so a lot of stuff has been
released they're johnson tapes they're
tapes of the white house that are there
um and i would have been glad had that
stuff been available then to use it the
uh the the reason i didn't put the list
of interviews in at the time was that it
was the height of
the nixon era where they had done they
were going after people who'd done the
pentagon papers they were subpoena
people i had been called because i knew
dan ellsberg
and had interviewed him i was in fact
subpoenaed and i was called in a court
case where if they they eventually threw
the case out but i was facing jail time
uh for just having known dan ellsworth
was a very different time and i did not
they were they were really doing some
witch-hunting a bit then and i did not
want my sources to be uh
i wanted my sources to be protective and
i and and i could not give that list at
that time i could in retrospect now i
mean i could but for whatever reason it
is now a done deal and it would almost
seem like tampering with the book to add
on
in effect posthumously in your in your
current book you do talk about who you
who uh you interviewed and you note two
people would not talk to you yeah sam
nunn president that was surprising
because i had met him a couple of times
we seemed to get on we had a very nice
day together once in nantucket at a
meeting of a bunch of senators and i
liked him and so and he was a person who
knew a lot about this because he'd been
in the senate during the during this
period and i was willing to go down to
atlanta and i made a lot of phone calls
and i find it
and he and i got back the word he won't
do it and it was never clear why and i
think maybe he was just pulling back
from that part of his life i wasn't
i wasn't uh
really clear as to why and then of
course clinton himself who when the war
uh when when he left uh wrote me a note
about something else i wrote and
clearly was when he was taking a real
pounding on mark rich and his stock was
at the lowest moment
and he
and i'd written something that
that was critical but i think he thought
in retrospect taking all the other abuse
was more sympathetic and i got a nice
note from him saying let's talk so i
there upon began to call regularly i
called about six times hoping to get
together for the book and including one
call to betty curry his
personal secretary and he never returned
any call which i which didn't surprise
me i didn't think he
wanted to deal with a reporter who was
by then as well prepared as i was i
think the president by then or former
president liked to deal with people who
hadn't done as much homework
next call for you is from winston uh
sorry first los angeles you're on for
david howard stan good morning mr albert
sam how are you
i'm fine
very well i've been a big fan of your
books for years and uh i have a question
in making of a quagmire
and i don't know the details i haven't
read it in probably 20 years
two advisors were sent to vietnam to
assess our goings on there and report
back to kennedy i believe
they were given tours by separate people
and i believe that the upshot of the
whole thing is that kennedy asked
if they in fact went to the same country
because they're can you discuss that
real briefly yeah i think it was two
people one was a there was a civilian
guy and a military guy i'm trying to
think of who the civilian was maybe
whether it was roger hillsman or someone
like that and the military person was uh
brute crewak who was the uh
the military guy on vietnam and uh
krulak apparently came back and you know
said oh things are really going very
very well when clearly by then the war
was very was over my friend neil sheehan
later got to know krulak and like krulak
was later calming down to the marine
corps
um and um
and he was and his son was coming down
to the marine corps as well chuck and
that's a uh i think brute was a comet
and i know his son was certainly brute
got to be at least three stars um
he got to know my friend neil sheehan
very well when neil was doing a
a bright shining lie and he swore
to kneel
that he did not
rig the thing that by the time he got to
vietnam in the late fall of 63 and he
did all this interviewing
of the senior advisers there that what
he brought back
was what they told him and uh and that
therefore he'd been
bam i gathered bamboozled by them as
well i mean he shouldn't have been it
should have been should have been a way
of finding out and going to lower levels
that what we were saying was
was uh
that what we were saying is reporters
was true and that the war wasn't going
well i'm i'm a little suspicious of what
uh the senior krulak said because he was
really uh someone who had really been
one of the people trying to destroy my
career and and spreading scurrilous
stories about me when i was there i
uh there was a time time magazine in
those old days back in 63 had a little
house letter that it would use to put up
and it took a lot of gossipy stuff and
it didn't put in the magazine but it put
it into this insider's letter and one of
the stories there was that uh was from
krulak which is that quoting another
reporter that i had looked at a bunch of
viet cong bodies and had burst into
tears and that was in the context of
1963 supposed to be you know enormously
destructive to show me as a uh as a wimp
and a [ __ ] and a guy who was not to be
counted on as a combat correspondent so
i in fact grabbed him at the airport i
found out about and grabbed and i said
don't you ever put [ __ ] like that out on
me again i mean i really was ferocious
uh fierce furious about that because it
was a scurrilous thing and it was really
designed to to to dim it to damage your
career the truth is in retrospect i if
i've seen bodies of the viet cong i
probably should have left i should have
wept for everybody i saw there
next call and question comes from
winston-salem north carolina
and it sounds like we actually lost them
let's uh let me go back to uh email this
is from a fellow
in plantation florida r.a grant
who asks a process question for you i'm
curious if your books always start and
end on the intended path or rather
change direction during your process for
example summer of 64 was as much social
interaction and racism as it was about
baseball was this your intention
yes i think i mean the answer is on both
questions is
that um
but the books change a lot books have an
orbital thrust of their own
and you start a book thinking it's going
to be about one thing and then you get
in and it it has a truth and you follow
the truth you you do very well
not to lock in
on what you think the book is the book
begins with a question why did such and
such
happen
and
and then you follow
that trajectory but the trajectory can
change
but let me go back to october 64. when
i'd done summer 49 it was the last
moment it was a previous baseball book
of an all-white era i mean by jackie
robinson had come aboard and willie mays
was about to appear but it was
essentially
a white world
in october 64 i did it in no small part
because of race because the yankees
while not entirely lilly white had
fought the coming of the black players
whereas the cardinals with a bill white
kirk flood lou brock and in particular
bob gibson had opened the doors to great
black talent and great black athleticism
and so i saw something symbolic there
that one team had used the new forces at
play at our society and one had resisted
them but you are always
adapting in a book when i began the most
recent book
born in time of peace it began by being
my being at a cocktail party in um in
the spring of
not two years ago 99 and being with my
friend les gelb and the bombing of
kosovo's going on and i ask him who's
driving it is it as the media says
madeleine albright
and
he says no actually it's
the vice president gore
and i think well that's really
interesting and i'm out of that loop and
i ought to know more about that loop i
had to find that out so i called my
friend grayden carter at vanity fair and
said why don't i do a piece
on who drove the bomb he's a great idea
do it so it begins as a magazine piece
then i do
a little bit of reporting
and
i
and i realized it's more than a magazine
piece that there's a really an
interesting question here are we a which
i try and answer in the book are we a
monopoly superpower that is a de facto
isolationist nation
i mean and if so how and why did this
happen and i started interviewing more
and so i go to my publisher and i say
let's make it a small essay book
to a book a small essay book 35 000
words and they say fine and it's not
going to be much money but we'll work it
out so i do some more interviewing and i
begin to get the shadow of vietnam
the impact of vietnam on two
institutions vital to the country very
damaging i mean most of the rest of us
have gone on to our lives
but it has been very damaging to
it's been very damaging to the united
states army because we sent a good in
korea we sent over a bad army and got
back a good army in vietnam we sent over
a good army and got back a army with a
virus i mean bad army colin powell
writes very very well about this about
you know the inflated metals inflated
promotions of the the toxins that got in
because of the the wrong people promoted
he's the proudest of anything he's done
in this in his public life on helping to
be one of the people who has
cleansed the army so i thought the i
didn't seek the shadow of vietnam
but it's there and i went to dinner
about two months into it with bob
woodward and i'm my colleague who's done
all these extraordinary bits of
reporting and i
and we're talking he says it's your
successor book to the best and the
brightest and i start thinking i think
he's right so that night i've been
staying at the jefferson hotel here i've
got the
i write i don't have my computer with me
or printer i hand write a letter of
about five pages to my lawyer agent
saying i have hit a mine a vein a good
rich vein this is a new book it is a
full book it tells what vietnam has done
the shadow to all these things and i
mean among it's not just are we
isolationists but it's how and why and
it's what vietnam did i hand print it
and send it off and with this if it goes
from being
magazine article to small book to full
book so you are always listening
to your book
i mean the book changes and you have to
adapt to those changes if you go in
people tell you things and you think
i mean i can tell you
again let me give you an example in
the year of september 2000 i'm i think
the book is done i come down from my
final interview to washington and i'm
going to see general wesley clark who
was the commander
of the american forces in kosovo we we
go we talked for probably an hour and a
half maybe two hours i've forgotten the
exact length and i come out of there and
i think the book is done by now
i think hmm
very bright
commander of forces there and he's been
squeezed out and virtually fired
i've got to reopen the book so i did six
more months
of interviewing based on that interview
that i wasn't there yet you have to
listen to your own book woody creek
colorado
hunter thompson country
yeah he's the neighbor um
thank you for being on c-span thank you
for having me on the new uh
bernard fall
and what effects his books had on you
well i did know him and he was a
wonderful colleague
and a wonderful friend
there's a moment is somewhere in the
vast archives of the new york times
there is a very angry letter i wrote
about jane fonda because there had been
a
an article in the new york times
magazine this was long after bernard was
killed
and
someone had asked jane fonda you know do
you read this was in her big left wing
state um
stage uh do you
read what do you read and she listed
some people and then the the interviewer
asked what about bernard fall
i wouldn't and there was some real
condescending phrase about him and i
wrote
one of the angriest five or six lines
i've ever written in my life bernie fall
was a great teacher to the generation of
vietnam reporters that i belong to to
neil to peter to charlie moore i mean he
was a wonderful man he was very brave he
wrote for
he what he wrote for home well he really
wrote
books i mean he would write occasionally
for magazines i guess he was in the new
republic or whatever
and he was loved by the men he was he
you know he he had the history of that
war was in his brain i mean he covered
the french war and he loved america he
taught i think here at howard in
washington a wonderful man and he taught
the rest of us
when about two years ago my wife and i
were back in vietnam for the second time
since the war was over we went i'd
always wanted to go to diane bianco and
um
because that's the famous battle and we
got there and we walked it
and i'd really read bernard wrote a
wonderful book called
blanking out on his book on diane bien
foo
but um
death in a very small place
great book
on the battle of the ambient film and
i
walked the battlefield but i wasn't
getting it wasn't getting it and i
stayed up that night all night rereading
bernard on it
and then i walked it the next day and i
got it and i got it and we were there
and there's almost you know the
vietnamese aren't very good
at souvenirs or battle monuments i mean
they're not this pretty primitive
society i mean here's a place that is
really like in fact gettysburg for that
right it's a famous place but there's
not much but there's somebody is farming
roses there
and we're walking about where the final
the castrice's
headquarters are where there is a little
monument and there's a rose field and
there's a woman there and i
buy three roses
from her
and then i press them
in bernard's book
on the way home so that i have on my
desk the dried leaves of roses pressed
in bernard's book from diane villanfo
which is one of the most heartbreaking
battles on both sides the french and the
viet minh that one could imagine the
bravery of both sides i mean so i mean i
loved bernie he was a great teacher he
was
held in a very small place is one of the
great books on vietnam on the great
battle accounts i mean we've recently
had some other ones uh mark bowden doing
black hawk down and my friend general
hallmore and joe galloway doing uh
we were soldiers once and young but but
helen a very small place is really right
up there we're at the top of our third
hour of conversation with david
halberstam we're spending
all this time talking about his writing
career next call comes from arlington
virginia
hello you're on the air yeah hi um hello
mr halverston i just want to say how
much i really enjoyed your books over
the years um and i have two questions
for you basically uh one is if you would
maybe go into a little bit more depth
about what your next project is you had
alluded to it earlier in the program and
the second question is about the best
and the brightest and
uh as you have said
that book came out of an article for
harpers that you wrote on george bundy
and i was wondering if you would ever
talk to me george bundy after the
publication of best and brightest and
got his reaction and can you describe
your relationship with him and do you
feel or if you had any sort of
relationship to with him prior to the
publication
and do you feel the same way about him
as you do about robert mcnamara which
you expressed earlier in the show
no i don't feel i don't feel nearly as
as angry
i thought he also remained silent too
long although gradually late in life he
did admit bundy did that it was a
mistake but he did it
rather privately or in small forums and
i think that he was not as public in
trying to analyze what happened and when
he finally wrote he really didn't write
about vietnam he wrote about
disarmament um
we didn't have much of a relationship
he'd been dean of harvard when i was a
student editor
and we had dealt with each other i
wouldn't say with either lack of
affection or affection when i was doing
this book when i came back from vietnam
um scottie reston who knew him this was
in 1964 and he was bundy was the head of
the national security said oh you ought
to go over talk to bundy i'll set it up
and the word came back bundy didn't want
to see me uh
uh i think it was because he didn't want
to maybe i was contaminated or toxic by
then and considered too much of a
pessimist and this would hurt him with
lyndon johnson maybe he knew which way
the play was going
when i was doing the best and the
brightest i thought he treated me with
great condescension
and i remember one of the the two
interviews i did and this one was for
the magazine piece and one was for the
for the book and i
went to see him and at the end
it was 1969 it was october 1916 i think
it was the metro in the world series is
why i
remember it i said at the end why are
you silent why are you talking
and
and he said well i'm i'm not going to
talk about this and i said but you were
the dean of harvard you were this great
intellectual we all looked up to you
this [ __ ] war is tearing this country
apart and you must speak out and he said
you're very arrogant and i said no i
think you're the one
who's very arrogant
and we parted
with great coldness
and didn't see each other for a while i
walked out of there it was very
interesting to me um
i'd always had this great respect for
what bundy and people like that
represented the american elite the great
aristocracy
groton harvard all these you know secret
societies skull and bones and i came out
of there and i thought
it doesn't really mean that much does it
i mean he's he's like this is this is
an enormously important moment and he's
going to stand on the sidelines and not
do anything and maybe he's not what you
thought i mean maybe you and your own
traditions
are just as good i mean i thought of my
my grandfather coming over here from the
old country and i thought of my father
who had
been a medic in world war one and then
went on to college and medical school
very limited resources put himself
through and had been a combat surgeon in
world war ii and i thought of my own
journey i mean rather not a good student
but going to places like the south and
the congo and and vietnam and i thought
maybe i know more about the world than
he does maybe i've traveled more and
seen more of the underside i came away
with less respect for him
and an embryonic beginning a belief in
my own journey that i knew things that
maybe these people that i'd always taken
so seriously because they got such good
marks or had phds or did these things
that maybe they weren't as good as their
curriculum v time and maybe i was a
little better than mine it was a it was
we did see each other to answer your
question we louie hawking close
the and he
but he hated the book and he would
people he would much people brought up
to me he would mumble something like
it's not the bible it's not the bible
um
late in his life there was a dinner
party where lily alkin cost the
wonderful novelist who knew him
brought us
together and we got through the evening
i think we were both on our
best behavior but there was no warmth
and no feeling of the bundys that we
have to get together with the halberd
stems or on the halberd stems that we
have to get to with together with the
bundys sometime soon go ahead caller uh
yes as a great fan of your work and your
ability to sort of deconstruct
symbolism at different periods of time i
wonder if we could ask you to comment on
in the in the mainstream media maybe the
lack of courage or lack of outrage
in uh regarding the perceptions of
militant islamic fundament
fundamentalism versus islam
in the way that
say
kkk flies in the face of christianity
and and so forth to expand on that a
little bit i think a lot of people would
appreciate well
first let me do a disclaimer and that is
i've never worked in the middle east i'm
not an authority on the middle east i i
you know i've never written about it
don't consider my i mean i'm
i'm
low-grade expertise i wouldn't even put
the word expertise there and i don't
know a lot about islam i mean obviously
there is a
fierce force there within islam that is
driven driven by
poverty driven by anger towards i think
you know the corruption perhaps of the
saudi
royal family i mean there's a lot to be
angry about there and there probably are
people there who
look around and they are both angry
at what they think are the co-opted
regimes and they think those regimes
have been co-opted by the west
as opposed to being co-opted by them
themselves for their own narrow greedy
reasons
and they are enraged i think because
they see
a mighty
religion from part of the world
where
in their minds civilization began and
first flowered
trailing
in terms of accomplishment
the infidels
of the decadent west i mean i mean this
this dilemma if the west
is such a place of infidels if it is
so decadent
why is it rich and powerful
and we in islam
are poor
and often backward and that is a dilemma
that i think
enrages people and it particularly i
think enrages uh
the
islamic fundamentals now as to your
question about the media i think there's
been actually a lot of
difference between islam and then this
small rather violent minority which
killed sadat and would light and would
like to do and which i think threatens
you know right now the life of the
the the president of pakistan i mean i
think which is a you know sworn its real
enemies are in the islamic world not us
our next call for you comes from a
military town minot north dakota
hey god bless you c-span this is just
wonderful and uh
i'm a i'm a football fanatic but here on
sunday afternoon haberstein will trump
football anytime that's that's that
shows that the nfl is in really serious
decline thank you i just have a couple
quick comments i'll get off because
everybody wants to listen to you talk um
i love the two two book treatments i
would love to see by mr halberstam uh
one on the clinton presidency
and one on uh
the career and maybe the unappreciation
of roger maris thank you all hang up and
listen well thank you well we have a
north dakota
you know connection in our family too
jean
sannis halberstam is from valley city
north dakota she is i have to tell you
though
sir she's a she's a real new yorker as
someone will be if the nearest neighbor
is about 10 miles away i i like to joke
that if they if they ever close
down new york the last person crossing
out and leaving on the last bridge will
will be be my wife
i did write about roger maris by the way
at some length
in october 64. i mean there's i think a
very nice portrait of of a person a
country boy who is really ilities in the
city and also the first figure of the
media era i mean i think roger maris's
pursuit of the ruth record was the first
er great event of the new media
television age and he was uniquely ill
equipped to deal with it i mean the
yankees offered him uh
no protection now tell me what the first
part of the question was because i oh
about the clinton presidency the clinton
presidency there's a lot about the
clinton presidency in war in a time of
peace it is effectively a book that is
really about the clinton presidency i
mean a great deal of it uh so i thank
you for your kind words
you've changed publishers a few times
over the years we always do
and um when i was leaving when i was
finishing up my fourth book in a four
book contract with random house and i
was
anxious to do a book on
on a battle in the korean war up in the
yalu in november 1950 which i wanted to
do for a long time
they uh random house didn't seem very
interested i didn't i think they thought
it wouldn't get me on oprah and so uh
they weren't terribly interested so and
the people at scribner's were very
hospitable and have been and interesting
because they they took me really in a
way on blind faith and then this book
new book has done very very well so
they're i think they're very pleased and
there's some people who are rather
amused over at random house towards the
powers there who
let me leave you know that yellow river
book
over the years in biographical
interviews it keeps popping up when are
you going to get it finished well i was
i barely started and now with these
events the question is whether i'm going
to be pulled aside by events because
these new events are so transcending
that you're pulled to them i mean it's
very hard to do anything else now if
you're a journalist i mean the events
are so transcending and i'm feeling
pulled towards that
uh good afternoon
as a vietnam era vet i was always
frustrated with lyndon johnson's
micromanaging of the war
can you comment on that and uh
also
do you have any thoughts on on or if
lyndon johnson was afraid to win the war
well i don't think it was about afraid
to win it i think the war didn't work i
think they significantly underestimated
the dynamic that the other side had the
lack of vulnerability to i mean they
thought it could be done well the
architects of that war
particularly mcnamara thought that
american technology could do it uh that
particularly air power and they
underestimated a couple things one how
big the country is vietnam is a very
very big country and 500 000 troops
looks like a lot
but they get swallowed up they
underestimated what the night time would
do and the thick foliage and then it
turns out a third thing which we hadn't
even thought of which is this amazing
network of tunnels i mean miles and
miles and miles of tunnels so that even
if we were bombing them they were able
to you know open the in certain areas
north of saigon not very far away they
were they were really brilliant
engineering structures not for people
like you and me we couldn't fit in very
well but for people you know five foot
two or three and 130 pounds the you know
the air power they we over bet
on technology and what we could do and
the effectiveness the second thing was
we thought we overrated our ally the
south vietnamese and how effective we
they would be and we underestimated the
ability of the other side to keep
replenishing i think that we were we
were losing about ten thousand men a
year and we thought the and the people
with the architects like bill bundy
talked about tightening the ratchet on
the north
they
they were probably losing a hundred
thousand
men a year
it really was probably ten to one but
three hundred thousand young men were
coming into the draft age so they could
because it was their primacy their war
of independence it was a war of luxury
for us they could
take and accept a hundred thousand
as we could not
take the ten thousand there was a moment
in
1966 when my great colleague harrison
salisbury got a a
visit to north vietnam and he saw fanba
dongly north vietnamese prime minister
and they talked and
feminine said and how long do you
americans want to fight mr salisbury one
years two years three years five years
10 years 20 years
we will be glad to accommodate you they
would pay that price or the use of odd
phrase kennedy's speech pay the price
bear any burden because it was their war
of liberation and we underestimated that
we underestimate we overestimated what
the technology would do are you i have
to ask this quickly because your caller
been waiting but are you hearing those
same sorts of echoes when you turn on
the television today and you think i
think anybody nervous
well i think anybody who knows about
vietnam and knows about military power
is nervous about from day one about how
well our high technology power how much
how applicable it is here we know the
limits of it believe me colin powell and
the senior military know
that this is an enemy not lightly
vulnerable to high technology or and
that even elite forces like the delta
units is going to be a very tough thing
i mean i i think the great danger for
this society i think we can do this i
think we're strong resilient i think we
can
i don't know the word is win
but i think we can
be the stronger force in this very
difficult thing ahead but we need to be
strong
wise
and patient we are a society of
immediate gratification i think this
we're more v and i think that's our the
the immediacy the impatience is our
vulnerability i i worry about this the
stock mark the country's different from
what it was in 1941 it's a different
kind of enemy it's a harder enemy to to
to to attack and to assault but the
society is much more
connected
the norms it drives it revs faster uh
the the stock market in in 1941 only
tiny handful of americans were on the
stock market you could have long-range
goals in the private sector you didn't
have to drive the stock up for quarterly
reports
we have the the market makes our larger
companies uh much more predatory much
more impatient the media is much more
predatory
and impatient and demanding of answers
and demanding of stories it's a vast
pizza we talked a little bit about the
cable news channels 24 hours a day seven
i mean we've got to have news we got to
have this
a lot of things take take time are slow
there aren't answers answers are
complicated we don't lend ourselves much
to having people who talk this way on we
want people who will give answers and
give it quickly and give it now and this
is a real vulnerability and this is by
the way and bin laden has talked about
this he thinks that we are
vulnerable because of our impatience
that we are more impatient he said that
the russians would be easier to fight
because they were more patient than we
are i think he's going to be proved
wrong
but it's it is something that we should
be aware of for david howerst i'm next
decatur georgia
hello it's a pleasure listening to david
haberson
and uh i fought in vietnam in
1966 in the marine corps
and i was against the war
while we were killing those vietnamese
people
and uh i couldn't understand why we were
there in the first place
and after the war
i read i read that very book you're
talking about helen's very small place
by bernard bernard fall and i read
several other books by him and he he was
like you extremely objective
and not uh
subjective not spotting the pentagon's
propaganda
but uh uh extremely objective and i just
wanted i have a couple questions number
one
was he killed by the cia because he was
so objective in that war
and number two what's your stance
on the vietnam war and number three how
does that war relate to today's war
against afghanistan and osama
bin laden well thank you someone who
hasn't heard some of the earlier
conversations well first off bernard was
not killed by the cia i believe in 1967
he stepped on a land mine there i could
be wrong that it was a landmine but i
believe it was but he was killed in
combat there and he he didn't have to be
there he at his point he was
distinguished enough that he didn't have
to be out
in effect on point he he went out on
point because that's who he was and he
had a great zest for knowing and for
talking and and the legitimacy i mean
you know if you're a war correspondent
or someone like bernard you get
legitimacy by doing it you can't
uh you
you can't stay behind and get and and
and and do it from the back back
headquarters because the people who do
it aren't going to respect you only way
one way you can get the respect um as
for vietnam i just think it was the
wrong war at the wrong time in the wrong
place a tragic miscalculation driven by
fears of the mccarthy period and a
certain hubris of who we were and how an
arrogance of power that our technology
would work this well and third i do
think it's quite different from
afghanistan i mean i think we went 12
000 miles away gratuitously to something
that was not a national security crisis
did not threaten us the vietnamese were
not about to
attack los angeles or or san francisco
or hawaii i i think it was um
a major misreading of history and of
what end of the dom the domino theory i
mean this was a war of liberation and we
got in the way of their nationalism
whereas in the case of
of this is the world trade center tax
attacks and attack on the pentagon that
is people attacking us and turning uh
the home front into a war front i mean
that isn't i regard that as a
a de facto
declaration of war on us and i regard it
as a threat to the very fabric of our
society the freedom for the open society
the ability to have a something which is
really cherished to all of us to free
society to move about freely to do this
with confidence that you are okay going
to be protected and also that you know
you're not
bringing 10 documents to every place you
go to prove that you are you i i think
we're so lucky in this society we've
been so free we we're we're on our own
recognizance all the time and i like it
that way i'd hate to lose it so this is
a huge challenge to the way the free
society operates and everybody not just
in this country but i think in the world
has a stake in it because if the united
states can't deal with this all these
other democratic societies and these
embryonic democratic societies will be
proved to be vulnerable i know there are
a lot of people in europe these days who
are sort of enjoying a little bit the
fact that we are being tweaked or hurt
or wounded we've been immune for most of
the carnage of the last hundred years
which has been so hard world war one
places like ferdinand world war ii uh
most of the terrible things in the world
have really helped elsewhere i mean the
bombing in oklahoma city was the biggest
and that was us against us i mean it was
a domestic terrorist until then was you
know we were spared the carnage
now the carnage has come home and a lot
of people are sort of slightly well it's
america's turn but i believe they have a
stake in our being successful because if
we don't make it uh a lot of countries
that are not as strong will prove to be
vulnerable we have just about half an
hour left in our three-hour conversation
with david however stamina
seventh inning uh not time for a stretch
though we have a lot of callers oxnard
california you're next
hello mr halverstein i'm really enjoying
your show and i must say it's susan's
show with susan's show well
it seems like it's become your show in
my mind anyway thank you especially your
take on um
uh types of news coverage
but i mean i i just think the television
people really i mean they're you know i
mean
peter jennings is a high professional
and he's really good but he's the only
senior person
in the media anchorman who made his
bones as a foreign correspondent we have
turned inward so much that something
that
should have been almost a mandatory part
of a senior journalist curriculum vitae
in the most powerful nation in the world
which was to have spent at least five or
six years overseas in different
assignments so that you get a sense of
what the world is the others haven't
done it dan rather did a
tour of vietnam but that really isn't
being a foreign correspondent tom brokaw
came right up in american career and it
shows and i mean they got in in the
critical years 12 13 years last year
they got rid of their foreign
correspondents because it wasn't good
for the ratings and i think that that's
outrageous excuse me i didn't mean to
interrupt you sir you know what he's
gone uh let me ask you about party
politics for a minute last summer we had
our cameras at the democratic national
convention and you were there you were
on the speakers yeah it was an old
friendship with the gorf family i was a
young reporter in tennessee and
um nancy gore nancy gore-hunger was a
um
palomin and so when i've known the gore
family and the vice president forever so
when i so when i uh was asked he asked
would you know would i come and be part
of a group trying to validate his
background i said yes it wasn't
something i
terribly much wanted to do
because um i write book i mean i'm most
into daily if i was a new york times
reporter i couldn't do it because i
write books i have the freedom to do it
and if he he called into a chit and i
answered do you worry about people
thinking differently about your books
when you're involved i mean my books
speak for themselves i mean i think i
refer in the book to him running a
clunky campaign so i you know i think
i'm independent and i think i was
sitting there talking about the kind of
background he had i would have probably
all things
considered
preferred not to do it but he they they
had because they had been very nice to
me when i was a young man going way back
you know it is 42 years i covered i
covered the uh the senior gore's run for
reelection in 1958 and i just thought my
own reputation uh for integrity would
would would win out and i would you know
when i wrote about things if i wrote
about them i'd write about them straight
i mean i don't think anybody who
reads this book is going to think that
i'm a prisoner
of the clinton and gorge in fact i got a
a rave review in the wall street journal
which is usually uses me for target
practice uh
john layman former secretary of navy
wrote a very very admiring
review which said how honest i had been
about what you know the clinton gore
people and their national security
people had done in that decade
this is uh david haberstein's current
book available in any bookstore you walk
into around the country war in a time of
peace and as we listen to our next call
i'm just going to show you another
project he's associated with it's just
come out we only have a proof copy here
but it is a book about
september 11th in new york city let's
listen to a call from long island
california
this is long island new york sorry okay
please
thank you
hi susan it's a great program and mr
david this is just an opinion i don't
know if you agree with me or not but
before i i'd like to say one word before
i say the muslims and the arabs and the
situation now very sensitive especially
for the people who's living here
and before we say that hate
maybe it's not hate maybe it's anger
we put ourselves as
a security guard in the world
and they don't hate us because they look
at us as rich and they are poor they
look at us as
helpers
and they look at us as people who help
all the time whose
in poverty or problems and they look at
us as a solution
not as somebody to hit us
and
[Music]
this is the way they look at us as
american in other countries
and before we say about women and men
and all these relationships
because maybe they are happy the way
they are we don't know
as you said mister
stan that
you never visited the middle east maybe
you have to before we
say our opinion about these countries
we have to go there visit there
and be mixed with them or maybe talk to
people who's living there
from the united nations in the united
states and united nations
maybe uh they are happy the way they are
um i i don't think that's entire i mean
i think there's some things they're
happy about i think there's some things
they see of us on television that they
find attractive i think the informality
and i think that they and the the fact
that um
we are rich i think and they are poor
has allowed the people who say the fault
in their poverty the reason for their
poverty comes from us that we are the
cause of their poverty i think it makes
them unusually vulnerable to that kind
of propaganda i think that that the
people of bin laden and other people
have exploited the difference in
economic status very skillfully in all
this
i showed some photographs you don't
really have to comment on them but
people are curious about your writing
life and these are a series of photos
from you at work in new york city where
do you do a lot of your research well i
mean i do most of my research you know
interviewing but there's a wonderful
library the new york society i believe i
have a couple books out right now that
are overdue which i'll try and get back
to them until they're probably listening
it's a wonderful library old-fashioned
private i love going there it's a
brownstone on 79th street you know
and uh we also have photos by brian lamb
i do believe that's part of that that's
e-t eli zaybar's wonderful
food place on about 80th and uh 81st in
in madison and i like to go there after
i've worked some time for bite eating a
cappuccino brian wanted to share
cappuccino with me that day i should say
that these were all taken as part of our
first book notes book which was a
collection of authors and mr howard
stems book was featured in that santa
cruz california you're on for david
hauerstein well thank you very much for
c-span it's it's been wonderful
i'm a first time caller anytime anyplace
and i had a question when you mentioned
bernard ball in in 1965 i was teaching
civics in a high school here in
california and i remember a chapter in
one of his books
concerning a meeting at cardinal
spellman's apartment in new york city
in which uh kennedy and mike mansfield
and
i believe it was alan dulles's or maybe
john posted ellis's son
who was a month senior to
a spellman
where
the purpose of the of the meeting was to
promote the dms
as of the people that we should back in
vietnam and i haven't heard very much
about that since then particularly
mike mansfield's opposition to the war
when he seems to have been in on the
ground floor thank you very much i'll
i'll take my call online yeah bernard
wrote about that a number of us did
there was in the early days of
of vietnam and the anti-communism of the
mid 50s
in a country that was essentially
confucian hyphen buddhist
because of the french experience there
was a catholic minority and it ended up
having a and of course it was more
virulently anti-communist in the country
as a whole and there ended up being a
rather powerful lobby ford in this
country in the particularly in the 1950s
anti-communism and mike mansfield who is
a wonderful man died a few years ago
maybe as good a public person as we've
ever had i mean wonderful wonderful man
mike who swung around great deal on this
was part of it thinking you know this
guy nego dinziem and then the go family
was the best ticket and it turned out
that they were
rigid and hierarchical and they ended up
being a sort of catholic enclave in us
southern
country and they were people who'd in a
time of revolutionary war when
uh
ho and these people had driven the
french out museum and people like that
had stood on the sidelines so they
didn't really have i mean we kept
talking about him as being a nationalist
but he stayed out of the country yet
it'd be like talking about george
washington as a nationalist if he by the
way exited and stayed on the sidelines
and gone to france during the
revolutionary war
doug perry of fox island washington
wants to know what has been the most
satisfying writing experience for you
well mr perry i think it's the totality
of the career i think i think the great
privilege
to uh for it's 46 years as a journalist
i mean i the great coverage be able to
cover the early civil rights
movement the to be a young reporter in
vietnam when i think being a reporter
meant was so important because the
government was saying one thing and we
were saying another and i think when
when the government doesn't tell the
truth then journalism gets really
important and then now for so many years
writing books the ability to take a book
and something serious and spend three or
four five years doing it and have this
sort of covenant with your readers that
if you do your work well and make it
accessible i try and make my books
accessible there they're not written for
phds they're they're written for
seriously people and i i love the
resonance that we had of what we've had
for the last two and a half hours
because these are people who've i mean
these are all the homes i've gone into
for 30 years serious nice ordinary lay
people who've been calling it the
covenant i've done is that if i work my
side and bring you a story and try and
be straight and make it a good story and
anecdotal and give you
perceptions and
and help you to understand the
complicated world you're in that you'll
stay loyal
to me and and remain a reader and you'll
have me in your house
that's a great great privilege to to be
a free reporter in a free society at a
time when journalism has gotten far more
corporatized to be a ma pastor going out
every day kind of i sometimes refer to
myself as a rich man's willie loman i
mean willie loman you know
death of a salesman shoeshine and a
smile i'm a little better off than
willie but i mean i'm one person i make
my own phone calls i
get on airplanes and fly out to see
people and they take me in and they talk
to me i can't think of a
a more fulfilling
career a richness of it i mean so mr
perry's question it's really the
sum of it and what i
what i like susan is what it's done for
me i mean i think i'm a richer you know
i see that kind of callow young man that
started out we had some of the photos
from early days of vietnam and
uh skinny and black-haired and whatever
and i see the changes in the richness of
the life and the and it's from the
friendships and it's from the learning
curve it's from going out and
interviewing all these people and you
get to be a richer wiser person
our next call for you is from naples
california
go ahead caller
are you serious and you're going to
mention that book about the september
11th oh yes i think that's very
important because i'm a cameo in that
but it's such a beautiful book okay it's
magnum photographers let me let me do
this because i've got naples enables you
there
all right we do have lost them so let's
go to the magnum photographers we'll get
rome but lose naples
are they called i mean a magnum is a you
know a group of great photographers
starting going back to robert kappa and
some extraordinary people and it's a you
know consortium of photographers and
they asked me about three or four days
after
september 11th they'd brought these
brilliant photographs would i write an
introduction i'm a cameo on this but the
photographs
are dazzling and i'm very proud to be
part of this as i'm proud there's
another book that i wrote the
introduction to requiem which i think
maybe i'm as proud of anything that's um
my friend horse foss was really critical
in that and it's nothing but photographs
by photographers who were killed in the
vietnam war including people like
bernard faller in there henry huette
larry burroughs beloved friends that
book is so beautiful of all the things
that i'm part of i can't think of
anything that i'm prouder to be part of
well i'm told that naples is there so
we'll look at some of the photographs of
horst fawz as we listen to them tim page
tim page did that with horsewatch and
we'll listen to this caller go ahead
please yes thank you for the opportunity
to to address mr halperstein i was a
graduate student in 1967 late 1967 i
worked a lot with g mccarthy
in the philadelphia area and uh
at that point in time
we really were
gathering forces to effectively oppose
the war my question really deals with
robert kennedy uh the that offensive
occurred
in uh
uh february 68 right and effectively
we we effectively thought that we had
carried the water essentially and that
perhaps uh mr kennedy was we didn't
consider him perhaps an opportunist uh i
was wanting your opinion concerning that
well i liked gene mccarthy and i like um
bobby kennedy i was very fond of bobby
kennedy i think mccarthy went in first i
think kennedy made a mistake in not
going in earlier and i think when but
when the ted offensive happened and
bobby got in
uh he took a lot of hits for coming in
uh more slowly but i think he also
thought and i think rightfully that he
could approach approach
far broader and create far broader
constituencies than gene mccarthy did
and there was always a question of you
know how hard gene mccarthy was willing
to work in that particular campaign
would he really campaign hard enough to
to bring that home and i know there's
still a lot of bitterness on the part of
some of the mccarthy people towards
robert kennedy i i thought they both
were extraordinary
he along with ho one of the few people
to get specific treatment from you in a
book you know small book i did a small
book after the campaign on robert
kennedy
next call is from irvine california
you're on for david halperstein hi mr
halberstam you talk a lot about the
difference between wealth in the united
states and in the middle east and i was
wondering if you've ever given any
thought to how wealth is created and why
the united states is by far the
wealthiest nation
that has ever existed and i have my own
views on how wealth is created but i'd
like to hear yours and well i mean
something i ponder all the time and i
you know what are our blessings that
have done this
obviously the the size of our land the
climate the richness of the soil the
fact that we were for a very long time
self-sufficient in energy when
uh
that was more important we had copper
and all these things i mean the
climate's not to be underestimated the
size the land mass but more recently
land mass and mineral wealth is is far
less important i would think that it's
the dynamic of the society the the
tempered capitalism the immigration
policy which makes us renews us all time
i would put in a factor of our great
land grant universities i think that you
know we have harvard yale princeton and
uh the british have oxford cambridge and
and london school and the french have
they called polytechnic and sorbonne but
we have ann arbor champaign illinois
we've got you know lafayette purdue in
lafayette university of indiana
bloomington uh we've got the california
system the of great universities like
the nation of california we've got all
the schools around boston i think the
ability in one generation to rise above
your
parents in this society the fluidity the
meritocracy the lack of hierarchy is the
i think we more than any society
summon
uh
the talents more of our talent of our
people i think you can be in this
country
of
who you want to be the person of your
dreams more like more likely than any
other place i i think the combination of
i think it's our openness
our immigration policies are great great
land great grant state universities i
just think that we are sort of blessed
in that and it makes us regenerative so
that even after we end an area era where
the blue-collar economy turns into a new
high-tech or we end an era where
agriculture was so much more important
or end an era in which mineral work
value was so minimal resource was so
important we keep being rich and strong
and i i think we have i think a lot of
it really is from the the university
system and the immigration system and
the openness and the the tolerance
that's built in the freedom i think our
freedoms i think the freer we are
the stronger we are
and the richer we are now that sounds
simplistic i mean a lot of people there
are a lot of people out there who don't
who want us to have less freedom in
their own society think oh there's too
much debate or there's too much of this
or there's too much this on television
or whatever but in the end it's our very
freedoms it's the first amendment which
isn't just applicable to
you know what the new york times prints
it's it's a larger thing that we are who
we want to be
and that i think turns and morphs right
into the private sector i i think one of
the interesting things about the 60s
everybody a lot of people critics
conservative critics who are very
critical about the 60s what they think
is this terrible time in america
i think it had a great effect on the
private sector i think you know from the
era i went to school in where you know
if you want to go in the private sector
you went into one of five or six big
companies u.s deal or 4g
general general electric general motors
and that
suddenly
the winds of change of going out and
starting up your own company in the 60s
swept through the private sector as well
and we got a much more explosive economy
in the 70s and 80s i mean that's my own
personal feeling
there's a question from don ballard of
fremont california and it gets us into
one of your books we haven't talked
about he asked what is the defining
moment of the 50s i might also ask why
was it important to write about that
decade
well i think it's a very i mean i just
wanted to write that book because i grew
up in the 50s i went to college in 51 i
graduated in 55 i covered the early
civil rights thing i met elvis uh in 56
i guess in nashville
i covered martin king in
in 55 56 i covered the emmett till trial
i i saw all these things happen and i
think so much of what happened in the
decade of the 60s was seeded prepared
in the decade of the fifties so i
thought it'd be interesting as someone
who is becoming more of a historian to
go back into the roots of these things
and find out what they happen
defining acts a couple things i would
think one would be
brown versus board of education in 1954.
i suppose the moment when ed sullivan
says that he's never going to put elvis
presley on and then elvis goes on
uh in 19
i guess it's around 57 he goes on the
rival steve allen show which has never
beaten ed sullivan and steve allen has
these high
ratings uh and ed sullivan surrenders um
and immediately puts elvis on and that's
the beginning of the popular culture in
a youth culture i think these are a
couple they're probably about four or
five others but i'll throw those out
warren pennsylvania go ahead i have a
both a suggestion and a question the
suggestion is that i would look forward
greatly to you doing a book
on turkey where they've made a
tremendous attempt to combine islam in
the modern world that's the suggestion
it's an interesting idea it's a nice
it's a i like the way you phrase that i
think it's an interesting point can you
bring it in i mean it's a very good
description
right and my question is uh especially
in light of your comments about the
universities do you think it's time to
bring the rotc units back onto our elite
never thought they should have left i'm
a dissenter i'm a person who really
doesn't i mean i know the military likes
the idea of an all-voluntary army but i
thought the draft was a
democratic thing i thought it was good
for all americans to have some idea all
americans young people to have some
sense of
larger obligation public service whether
you know it's military or something else
in a hospital whatever i think that it's
a healthier thing i never thought rotc
should have been booed off the
campuses of
of harvard or yale i think it's a good
thing i think that the more you have us
officers from all over the country uh
the better it is i i happen to admire
greatly
the the senior military men they've been
my phrase friends i really like hal
moore who wrote we were soldiers once
and young i like colin powell i like
jack galvin who was a four star and
sakura and later dean of the fletcher
school i like john i mean we have
it's not just the grunts i knew and the
young officers in vietnam the senior
people we've turned out john shelley
cashfield these are very superior men
and the more we get them from all
schools and including our elite schools
the better for everyone portland oregon
your question
uh yes uh i want to thank c-span 2 for
its presentation here and my question or
comment and i'd like uh mr hellerson to
comment on this is that
i have a feeling that our history
in the post-world war ii era fighting
communism and whatnot we have supported
as foreign policy some of the most
pernicious dictatorships that really are
really rude to their uh own peoples and
what not all in the all in the uh
uh
way of fighting communism and whatnot
and and also uh uh knocking socialism
and whatnot as has been expressed in
western europe and whatnot and i was
wondering as a possibility what we did
in japan
in reforming uh property rights and and
allowing
a redistribution of property rights i
read that book the bright shining light
and this guy john paul vann
was uh was saying that uh this is what
needs to be done the reform of property
uh and just redistribution of that in
vietnam
and that would have given the uh that
would have given the uh well let me jump
in because our time's running out and
get her i i think that you know all that
sort of water under the bridge um there
was a lot of talk about land reform in
vietnam a man named wolf ladazinski had
gone over there we had done we'd been
rather i think effective in the
philippines and and in in in
japan i think in our post-war
stewardship i don't think we did
anything more effectively not in europe
and japan was very in vietnam the forces
against us in terms of land reform were
just too powerful there was a lot of
talk and not very much got done
and i think the other the dynamic of the
other side was just too powerful they
had a a hole they had a title to the
nation's nationalism and the people who
were our allies i remember the american
advisors in the early days in 62 63
these nice young egalitarian captains
and majors would go out and talk to
their counterpart about being you know
going out and being with the people and
being more democratic and changing and
they didn't understand that most of
their counterparts were upper class
would have fingernails that long as a
way of showing that they didn't mess
with the ordinary people they didn't
want to narrow the gap between
themselves and the peasants
more often than not they wanted to widen
it and so we were sitting there full of
our egalitarian spirit and no one was
listening which is one of the great
lessons in terms of something that is so
easily thrown out the phrase nation
building i'll do nation building well
nation building if nation building has
to come indigenously nations have to
build themselves you can't come in from
the outside and say oh they're going to
teach you
the nation built i mean they either do
it and they indigenously have an
instinct of how to modernize themselves
or it can't be done i mean
and often it can't be done because the
forces in charge don't want to modernize
because if they modernize they will put
their own rule and and source of power
at risk the third leg of your power
study the reckoning how does it look to
you given the fact that japan which was
the other half of the equation has had
their economy tank well
i caught them on the rise when they
challenged us and we were doing a lot of
things wrong that was the hardest book i
ever did because it was really an alien
subject and and v japan is hard to write
about in that in the book i you know i
was
proud one year the wall street journal
did a a check of i think 400 ceos and it
was chosen as the
they thought the best book on business
that year i mean what happened japan had
this great run flattened out and is now
having some of the problems or more
serious problems than we had at the time
at that time
they had with their quality products had
caught us when we were asleep and they
had challenged us to go back and be
better than we were and be as good as we
used to be there was a moment which i
was writing about where they seemed to
be and were the true heirs of the
original henry ford in terms of high
quality manufacture our time's
evaporating next call for you comes from
chicago
um yes first let me say thank you susan
and c-span for allowing me to ask this
question
and even though i haven't gotten my
tours done for sunday and enjoyed this
beautiful day i am very happy to learn
more about mr halderstein and look
forward to reading what will be my first
novel of his um
my question
let me preface it could be based on just
anger after the september 11th
incident as well as confusion at the
purpose of
the big weapon we have i haven't heard
this question and i'd like to hear your
comments
on
why
um
if this is not the intent
of
the use of this weapon why we have not
and if it had
why
the reason we don't use it is very
simply
it's inapplicable and we would kill
so many civilians um and if you wanted
to pass on to your children and mine and
everybody else's children an islamic
world where everybody hated america and
was sworn to get revenge in their
lifetime then you would want to go ahead
and use the bomb if you want to try and
have a world where in some way you can
have some degree of mutuality of respect
and
diminish this kind of act of terrorism
and if even if we are not loved we will
be respected and and not have a sworn
enemy there then you are much more
disciplined in your use of force but if
we use the atomic weapon we will take
this thing and we will do their
recruiting for them for the next 50
years in one strike
will its california
yes
first i'd like to pay tribute to your
guest for
his book the unfinished odyssey of
robert kennedy
which i thought captured that era
very well and i guess my question is
somewhat related
would he
compare the sort of marketed presidency
or the marketed politician
versus the
civic
politician of that time
well
you know you get you're going to get
into a different era because i mean the
kennedys were the first people who
really knew how to use television they
the john kennedy was our first
television president understood the
camera understood how to do it and since
then we've really become i mean
television has taken over and it is more
more when i started out as a young
reporter i mean when candidates went out
to run for the presidency you really
covered them in the field and you watch
them with people now it's all done
by television it's all sort of
artificial even when they go out into
the interior of the country it's always
a television stage i mean it's artfully
arranged where they'll be popular where
they'll get a good background people in
native dress or something like that or
jimmy carter going down the mississippi
river on an old
steamboat or something i mean it's all
about a television stage so it's
increasingly i regret to say artificial
i don't know if you get into the
business of
rating presidents but in the 50 years
that you've covered in your journalism
here can you say when is the time that
americans had the most effective
leadership in the white house
um
well i mean on the presidency i mean i
think truman really i mean i think he
was
out of office by the i mean i was a
young college journalist in his latter
days i think
he was obviously effective i think
eisenhower was always underrated you
can't really judge john kennedy because
it's a meteor he was so bright talented
and he was struck down we never got the
second term i think he would have been a
very good president with a second term
lyndon johnson was impaled upon his
hubris in the war so the things that he
did in civil rights and and in the great
society never really
are going to counterbalance his uh
uh his weaknesses his strengths are
always going to be overshadowed by the
tragedy of the war
nixon had all that talent and strategic
sense but a a terrible vulnerability and
insecurity and anger raging out at
ordinary people often people who had
elected him and and uh
and voted for him so i mean i think the
the technical skills were uh
were were diminished by the emotional
ones i think gerald ford is a much
underestimated president who um
really the country owes something to i
mean i think he was a good and decent
man
and
was
you know an accidental president who was
reflected many of our better qualities
and didn't have that manic
obsessive
quality that you need to uh
to be that you now need i mean where you
the the the the
the glandular
sense is so dominant that uh everything
in life is given over to being president
i mean there was i think one things i
like about ford was the normality of him
um
jimmy carter
so bright
and a really other good politician until
he got into the white house at which
point he sort of decided that he was
above politics a number of things that
we ought to be started the camp david
process which is a big big plus uh did
the panama canal uh uh i mean can you
imagine that the hot button issue in
1976 when reagan ran against ford was
the panama canal it seems awfully
trivial now
reagan is just you know an american
enigma to me i mean all kinds of people
got him i didn't get him but obviously i
never thought post-vietnam
we were weak
and post
a shah of iran i mean i just thought
vietnam was a mistake i didn't think the
country was weak but a lot of people in
the country thought that was weak and so
the idea of reagan as you know it's
still mourning in america obviously he
reached ordinary people in a way in this
country and hit notes with them that i
didn't understand so i stand back and
almost admiringly just think that's one
i got wrong i mean i never would have
understood reagan i didn't understand
his relationship with the ordinary
american people by god he really had it
and he made them feel better at america
about america at a time when america
they didn't feel
so well about america and
bush tended to be underestimated i think
in qualities because he's not verbal
and i mean language was difficult he
could not articulate things but i think
he will probably end up getting higher
marks than his contemporary uh
uh graders are inclined to give
and clinton is going to be as rich a
vein to mind for historians as nixon
because you've got all that talent all
that skill and it's going to be because
of the lewinsky scandal the presidency
that might have been i mean people are
going to sit there and debate it they're
going to look at that talent they're
going to see all the ability the natural
goods he's probably the most naturally
gifted politician
that one has watched in the sense that
reagan had great great gifts but he was
also
riding a wave he helped drive the wave
of the country becoming more
conservative the affluence the
demographic changed affluence moving
from the northeast to the south and
southwest clinton flew in the face of
powerful demographic changes i mean he
was really going against a powerful
current i mean so the skills are
enormous and in the end um
the degree of achievement is going to be
ferociously debated we're going to end
with a call because our time is almost
out to custody did we do that did we run
down the president's okay on that one
thank you
can we leave anybody out i mean he did
not leave anyone out decasta florida
you're last go ahead yes i'm on
this houston yeah uh this is robert
reese from robert whitey reese from
tequesta florida former major league
baseball born and reared most of my life
in st louis missouri and in 1947 i was
with the st louis cardinals when the
brooklyn dodgers came to sportsmen's
park
and jackie robinson who has been trained
as an infielder captain in the army and
his
vast
background with his brother running
second to jesse owen in 1936 in the 200
meter dash
for that against the fascist german
adolf hitler
i saw a strike amongst my ball players
put down by the owners saying that we
would bring in the columbus
and the uh rochester team and replace
them point-blank got fired with no
retribution however they said we'll play
and they heard some invectors of jackie
robinson who i think is the most
courageous man that ever lived and the
silent uh he didn't
play so hard but my point was this
i'm reading right now the golden age by
gore vidal
i'm reading william turner's
and your question is but my question was
this
on september 11th my beloved city new
york i took the ten volumes that
mrs burns put out about our history of
new york from 1620 up to the building of
the empire state building and i used to
go down and marvel at that twin tower
well we're still there we're stronger
than ever
we're resilient come visit us it's a
great time to come to new york we're not
always warm and fuzzy and
and generous but this is a good time
people are being we found strength in
each other the more you're out with
other people the better you are
new yorkers are being very hospitable
these days other than i suppose if
you're from seattle oakland or uh
or korean pitcher for the diamondbacks
but
it's a terrific time please come and
visit the mayor has done i think a
brilliant job the taxi cab drivers are
almost polite a lot of our best
restaurants are pretty easy to get into
the theaters i don't often do
commercials but i if you're a new yorker
you're really proud of the city right
now you're proud to be from new york
you're proud of this country and the
resilience of the firemen have been just
magnificent the cops this is a very good
time to feel to see the strength that
great resilience of ordinary americans
and the nice thing with that caller and
his memories we managed to cover much of
what you call the arc of your career
from sports to race relations to new
york city so been a rich 46 year career
well thank you for
sharing we got to the ninth inning
and this is the current book we
encourage you if you haven't read david
hauberstein after this conversation to
sample some of his work in war and a
time of peace available in bookstores
now and our thanks to you for watching
and for all those great questions we had
next month on in-depth david mccullough
joins us for a three-hour interview